you look I mean where the frick should I
really even start I've got hold
[Music]
this is a serious message to all victims
of goblin mode I would like to issue an
apology thank you thank you
[Music]
what happens if I do it at the top
I thought why not we'll get up we'll get
our first button at the top what the
well welcome to the show everybody
what the
welcome everybody to the H3 podcast
I just hit the button at the top of the
show never been done before
we'll see
we'll see what happens
today we have a little bit of a bizarre
episode here for you guys
because one I just hit the button at the
top but that's not why right two
a b and Lena
come back from their wonderful family
vacation you guys had a good time by the
way B oh yeah good time good man
and uh have you guys spent have you had
any moment to work on the uh levels of
your audio or
that was suddenly Extremely Loud eBay
go ahead baby say something
okay you're good now you're good okay
yeah you guys had a great time huh you
guys went to Disney you guys went to
Universal
yeah
good time with the family good time huh
and so they came into work today
happy to be back glad to have you back
buddy
thank you and they come into work today
and uh I guess you weren't feeling you
were feeling fine when you came to work
yeah I was feeling fine and then I
started
feel a little crappy and I thought it
was the McDonald's I had for breakfast
oh yeah is it McDonald's or covid you
never know
right what did you have at McDonald's
uh I had egg and cheese uh McMuffin and
a hash brown you know what it is it's
the hash brown they're always just it
does too much I'm gonna need to break it
yeah those eggshells so so wasn't the
McDonald's though you you actually test
your test was like hardcore positive
yeah and I asked Lena to come take a
second look because it I couldn't
believe it after all this time you never
had it before I never have well oh wow
and Lena never had it before
correct because she also tested positive
this morning after you
yeah huh
and then you were with the crew
so what happened yesterday a b and Lena
came or was it just a b
no they were both here
so you guys were both here working in
close proximity with everyone
yeah how close
not super close but I mean you know his
which is in the office we're all next 10
feet away from me so I don't know close
enough
who's the close I guess lean and ABC
close together yeah the next person in
line would be Ian and Olivia and Olivia
so congrats well Ian's about to get
covered for the fifth time I don't think
you're I think your body is about to
give out on you bro after you get
covered that many times I think you're
you're internal organs just turned to
goo
it isn't my first rodeo
far from it this means a seasoned Cowboy
of coven I feel I feel bad for Ian in
particular but Ian you've got covet like
three times right
yeah it's like um these little mystical
little people come and just Salt Bay it
right next to me over and over and it's
beautiful I I'm starting to just enjoy
you know
it feels like home and maybe did you
salt Bay Ian with kovid
I did not I did not I may have uh
potentially give it to Olivia because
this is the first day since I've worked
there that I bought Olivia a drink uh
unannounced because they had prime at
the gas station the flavor she liked did
you guys drink from the same drink no we
didn't drink something you know what I
have great news I put it in the fridge
to save her as like a little special
treat for later so I didn't open it so
thank God
that's the same bottle I don't know if
that the prime well the covet wouldn't
be an inside it would be outside
whoa Zach from home is dropping
fireballs
that might actually be the craziest it's
so perfect
holy
of all time so um
yeah I'll be honest I
well you guys are wearing math thank you
for doing that yeah I wasn't in the
office yesterday so I wasn't exposed but
I really do not want covid
I see some people confusing shop so it's
Dan Cam and me still in the studio yeah
I feel I feel pretty safe over here
Ian what is Cam's hockey
h H so yeah Dan is switching for Ian Ian
is at home eating snacks having a time
of his life
uh but we have the high committee uh
assembled here so that's good
easy Rudy come on I felt like either we
all have it already or we won't get it I
felt like whatever I do it's already GG
yeah I mean not me well yeah you're here
putting my neck out yeah that's true
I've had it three times already now too
and uh it just gets worse every time so
I hope I don't get it before also like
not to scare you guys that have oh it's
your first time so you guys are you guys
don't have to really worry about about
what I'm about to say but the research
that's coming out that kovid like
repeated kovids it's just there's so
many weird things about it I just do not
want a piece of that and
well and you Cam just said he's had it
three times as well oh Cam you've had it
three times yep and it just gets worse
every time it gets worse every day
in my experience
Ian lost his taste the first time and I
don't think you ever fully recovered
from that right Ian
things were never the same you know I
knew something was up when I walked in
the office today and Zach was wearing a
hat
something that was very strange oh
that's a weird energy here so you know
what I knew when something was off
I saw a post on the subreddit of Hassan
wearing a clydens clean water shirt on
Monday
oh I don't up dude and
ever since then let's see
Hassan got sick
foosi got arrested I don't know if we
can put that on on Hassan's shirt I
don't yeah I don't know and now Abe and
Lena have covid and potentially we all
have covid the only reason I'm here okay
is so that I have a a a plausible reason
to not go to the streamings on Sunday
I called Ethan to tell him what was
going on this morning and pretty much
the first thing out of his mouth is
oh I guess we can't do the streamies and
I pointed out that he wasn't exposed so
if anything
he has to go without us well no okay
fair haha very funny I'm I was never
gonna go by myself then well not by
yourself but with either I was never
gonna go just me neela you're the ones
that wanted to go it wasn't you guys
peer pressured me I would have never
gone understood but now here we are
you're going I'm not going and if you
guys aren't going I'm not going he blew
it I feel so bad
it's okay honestly you is yeah you had
no idea
where do you think you got it if you had
to guess
man we just had bad luck the whole time
with the family I don't know probably
Universal or Disney
they were here and there was a hurricane
and an earthquake that's all right my
nieces have ever even been on an
airplane they were so excited about this
and one day we had to just stay inside
the whole time
and now they they probably all have
covid too I mean if you right it's a
good shot of that I called them so far
so good
but uh we'll see
so thank you to Hassan for wearing the
Klein water shirt that has ruined our
week decimated our week
is he still sick are we I texted him I
said are we good for Thursday he said
yes
but now but now there's a kovitz right
does he want to come in and get sick oh
man no but if I get coveted dude and
then I bring that home then it's a
full-on apocalypse like you don't even
know so part of me was like I probably
shouldn't but then the other part of me
is like you know
I gotta do the show you know I gotta do
the show
well it's also like it'd be such a
tragedy if you didn't go to the Streamys
you know like yeah I agree such
attractive show that you're talking
about right is the Streamys the the live
stream I mean you know that matpat is
the host
I would be absolutely devastated if I
had if I couldn't go to the Streamys I
mean but golly you just break my heart
matpat but they probably have to have
some kind of covid policy there
I don't think it's a big public event
game theorist guy matpat yeah I like the
game theorist guy I'm sure he doesn't
want kovit either
he's a nice guy what what do you want me
to talk on him no I'm yeah gauging
your excitement for me you're trying
you're trying to provoke me to talking I
will never say a bad word about Matt
Matthew pat pat of hair
Patrick
matpat a dumb name such an incredible
job posting we have to go yeah we have
to go see matpat
you but you that's like one of Olivia's
Heroes okay she loves Game Theory
literally I know all about matpat he'd
probably come on the show
you can conduct the interview
I'll ask him Mega fan his content what's
his wife's name
Miss Pat
Mrs Pat nice try why are you worried
about my wife I'll tell you another
disaster that that befell me this
morning
Jeremiah I don't know how many times I
need to tell people do not bring
Donuts into the office every time
someone does I'm saying you are getting
official warning and if you do it again
you're gonna be fired on the spot no
Donuts in the office what do I see when
I bring up here fat
bar chocolate bar and you know I crushed
that whole goddamn thing and now I feel
like
is it covet or see I just got here I
wouldn't even have it at all it wouldn't
make anything chocolate mocha you know
but I ate like a good part of that damn
donut and I feel like
hits you fast man
uh with peace and love the Droid and
Asaka
looks like the Droid version of Dan
this
in the new show
I don't see it personally but I'll show
it
I kind of see it I'll be honest how I
mean about it he's kind of he's kind of
got a beard we're really stretching this
on this point but there is something
there there's something there yeah his
eyes aren't even
Hazel those are yeah those are Ambush
yeah that's the biggest distinction no
hazel eyes so it's been a yeah it's been
a rough uh a rough morning
um
it's about to get rougher uh Vasco
donated 50 uh euros and said Dan can you
please tell Ethan he's got a giant
white blob between his lips so
distracted I'll end the podcast right
now I came here for you guys I didn't
have to I could cancel we didn't have a
sponsor why are you being so dismissive
50 euros they don't have 50 euros to let
you know to give you a heads up well
maybe you should show my monitor then
because you're not even showing my
monitor Dan I am it's because of the
zoom I I have the council up on that
screen so you can't see yourself but I
mean we can all see the black I would
never have a white blob we all see it I
will literally
I don't have to be here guys
I could be at home playing Baldur's Gate
3. that is you know what
you know what go on you're right maybe
we should just leave and do that
yeah
I'm at the end of act three baby
are you gonna start over when you beat
it
so
I really was already thinking about what
I would do if I played it again but
armored Core 6 comes out today
what that comes out to death and in two
weeks Starfield comes out hmm armored
Core is there any reviews out for that
game yet they're starting to come out I
saw some this morning and it people are
saying it's it's Aces baby
how's it called armored Core armored
Core see I know I don't know anything
about this series I know it's like their
seventh one somehow uh sixth
spot eight out of ten destructory nine
out of ten inverse 10 out of 10 IGN 8
out of 10. okay hero gamer 10 out of 10.
pretty good pretty hardcore it's got a
87 I mean I don't know if it's gonna be
my type of uh game
fair and but Starfield will be yeah sure
I'm stoked on that one as well
too many games this year too many games
I'm out on Diablo out of course you are
no I'm not played it literally I haven't
opened it
such a shitty game it's such a
disappointment
what do you got there Ian
wait is that it looks good what is it
it's a it's a grilled chicken yeah from
somewhere
let me see the let me see the side shot
the profile
it's uh it's the auto key is making it a
little difficult I think yeah okay
where's that from
can you see that yeah what do you think
about does it look good yeah I kind of
got the idea
I'm eating while I still can taste food
you're right I wasn't gonna say that
this is your last meal so might as well
enjoy it where's it from Ian
um
oh okay it's not it's just a it's a
private spot yeah it's very exclusive
looks good what sort of Chick-fil-A
please I don't like Chick-fil-A
I'll get I'd like to get a chicken
sandwich but Chick-fil-A is iffy really
yeah you know what I kind of know what
you mean just a little bit weird man
all right well this Show's been good
everybody we'll see you later your your
Mom is calling me oh is that what it is
yeah that's your mom all right let's
talk to my mom she sent us a message let
me tell her I need to
talk to her not there
she sent us a message
on Monday when we were in the middle of
the Colleen PowerPoint
and she says here let me read it
he's nuts she said these nuts
oh she's calling our WhatsApp group yeah
I don't think that's the right way to do
it right yep no it's not I'm sending
everything yeah I'm sending her the link
right now
so you can expect
very little from today's episode
which is part of the course yeah that
keep that standard
please all right here my mom said
yesterday mid
segment
she says I need the phone in about my
monarchs
I have sent a message on Tick Tock and
Twitter and thread and my neighborhood
app I have gifted forward a milkweed
plant to my next door neighbor and I
have asked him if he would gift forward
a milkweed plant to his neighbor I'm
hoping that my neighborhood becomes a
butterfly sanctuary
give the gift of butter of milkweed
today oh nice
that's sweet
so is she calling in
I sent her the link so uh hopefully
she'll be popping in in just a second
and by the way she's at the dog park so
you know it's gonna be good
also we have jax films calling in a
little bit yes look forward to talking
to him jack it off nice to touch
Facebook that's when we're moving we're
shaking today we're kicked out of
YouTube Partner program which is uh
cause for celebration of course
uh
I just gave up I'm even gonna try today
because like I don't even need to be
here okay I don't even need I wasn't
even supposed to be here this is all
bonus this is all a bonus seconds right
you were saying that Donna called in or
she texted mid-segment and I thought
that you were saying that during the
choline segment she texted you this is a
mid segment Ethan Donna
That'd Be Wild by the way uh tomorrow
morning 10 A.M
to all fans of Trixie and Teddy fresh
or people they just like to wear cool
stuff
10 AM PST tomorrow the collection is
dropping
it is dropping it is dropping it is
dropping oh wait Gila posted one rub
them together today let me pull that up
dropped a
grumpy
it is happening 10 a.m tomorrow people
here they are it's so good it's
happening right now
but it's not all like dresses and like
this is a shirt that really is nice I
must say
you know you have to say it
gotta say it
I gotta my pink denim on
show me
I'm showing it
I like that pink denim jacket it's
really cool it's great it's very high
quality thank you
all right well while we wait for my mom
oh here I have a gallery of all the
looks actually let me show you guys
she just popped into the lobby
all right
let me real quick as my mom connects
here's uh some previews we got the don't
touch me dress
are these oh I guess these stockings are
these called stockings oh I can I can
see everybody
the dress
the long sleeve tee the sweater hey Mom
one sec
the pants is also part of the collection
yeah
uh the vest
the shirt
the denim jacket yes yes yes yes yes
I think
the this is the shirt I'm wearing in
white
don't touch me
jogger it's really exciting
these pants are nice man I'll tell you
yeah
very cool stuff
this shirt these pants is a fantastic uh
combo man strong strong so there it is
10 AM PST thank you everybody hey Mom
hi guys are you at the dog park
[Applause]
what happened just chilling in Cedar
Rapids
why did the Mahjong game fall through
well
um
one of the girls had family and she
couldn't go to the beach and the other
girl wasn't able to come out here
because she's from LA and she commutes
and it's a whole you know women in their
drama
would you say they're being tell me
about it would you say that they're
being flaky
no it just life gets in the way you know
we'll play next week at the beach it'll
be fine
it'll be fine is there one of the ladies
that's more flaky than the others that's
like a little less dependable
no I wouldn't call any of them flaky
okay you know just you know us
grandmothers we have to watch our
grandchildren because the kids are out
of school one of them was on vacation
you know it's summer so what do you guys
talk about when you play mahjong
well some of the women that you're not
allowed to talk they get crazy because
they you know if you talk and you miss a
child and they get all upset they're
really intense I like to chit chat but
some of the women will even stick their
fingers in their ears because they can't
handle the noise so they'll get Snappy
if somebody's talking too much during
their turn
well I don't know if I'd call it snappy
but yeah they they they like it when
it's quiet has there ever been a
conflict over Mahjong verbally or
physically
no it's not like that no fights no
heated moments
right
both my grandmothers play Maj and I've
seen some go down at those
well you know
um we we disagree with each other about
certain things but it's never gotten
heated about the game wait wait Jack
your grandmother plays Mahjong where
does she live Valley
oh
oh is she up for another group
I'm sure she would be yeah oh my God
you're gonna have to give me her number
I could use some more players
yeah because all these flaky you
play with now oh no Ethan you're gonna
get me in trouble nobody's flaky I'm off
the grid baby I'm off the rails today I
don't give up
they're all very nice ladies when you
guys fight or when you guys are disagree
when you guys disagree is it over the
game or other stuff like politics
we don't talk politics because
there's a couple of us that are very
liberal-minded you know definitely
Democrats and then there's some women
there that are super Republican so none
of us talk politics you play Masha with
Maga grandmas
uh I don't know if I call a Maga but
there's there's a couple of women that
are hardcore Republicans so you know
they're nice women but just politically
we we just stay clear of that kind of
stuff that's a good idea that's a good
idea smart although I will say sometimes
I accuse some of the women for ganging
up on me
you feel they they gang up on you and
what and in what way
well because like someone will throw
something out and I'll Mahjong or I'll
take the tile and then they yell at The
Other Woman how can you do that you knew
Donna needed that child it's like I
don't know it's like I got a bullseye on
my on my forehead sometimes do you think
it's because you are a better player
that they're somehow forced to gang up
on you
strategic
well you know I think that sometimes
they are a little easier with some of
the other girls in the group do you
think it's because you're a lib no no
wait hold on this is something good now
the ladies you play with are easy to
defeat
you said they're easy
no no no you're better than they are
you're a better Mahjong player no no no
usually when we play I feel like you
said they're easy
no no
no they're easy
in that you know it's not easy you're
making it more out of it than what it is
anyways Ethan let's say let's not talk
about Mahjong well hold on Mama this is
interesting the butterflies can wait
I got nothing to do today I gotta fill
time
it's it's a sad State of Affairs though
when the culture War uh has hit the
Mahjong Meetup table it's tragic it
really is breaks my heart
[Music]
what button we are our you you revealed
where you are it's not a it's not a good
idea don't because we're live don't tell
your don't say your location during a
live broadcast okay yeah smash that
button but we have the buttons I
buttoned it out it's all good I'm
notorious for saying stuff like that
your fans are always screaming at me
Donna don't say where you are and I
still do it well one time you did it on
Tick Tock where the whole family was and
I was like what are you doing and then
you started arguing with us like what's
the big deal I was like just delete The
Tick Tock and you wouldn't do it
I don't remember that I remember that we
were in Vegas or something
remember that well
that's okay
no but we're all everybody's uh came out
on top but we're at two buttons already
which has got to be some kind of by uh
we're 26 minutes in I think that's
definitely a record one button every 15
minutes yeah
thanks
um so okay so so tell us about your
milkweed initiative Mom this is very
exciting
so in my backyard I have butterflies
coming and going all day long and I've
got milkweed you know most of our
backyard is is you know the pool and
cement and all along the border is where
I have the plants and the milkweed and
I've got so many caterpillars in
different stages on the milkweed that
it's like insane
so I need people to to Really step up
and support the Monarch so I I went to
the I went to Green Thumb and I bought
um a milkweed plant and I sent a message
to my next-door neighbor who you know
Ethan because he's in the music industry
anyways
um anyways I gave him a milkweed plant
in hopes that he would you know uh
also uh buy forward a milkweed planned
for one of his neighbors and they were
really sweet and said they were going to
do it because I you know my my goal is
to make our neighborhood like a
sanctuary you're Donna milkweed
yeah like Johnny Appleseed you're Donna
milk exactly exactly I mean one person
you know Supply and
it gives another person have you
followed up on your neighbor to make
sure he fulfilled his obligation
well I just gave it to him the other day
what window are we giving him to uh to
comply when we check up
well I'm sure you know I'll uh I'll
check up on them to see you know they
were really cute they said you know that
they would call
you know any any questions
so just make sure you open something up
on my neighborhood app you know a lot of
people
uh belong to their neighborhood apps and
I put something out on the neighborhood
apps and I got I got a lot of uh
response wow so hopefully and so another
good thing is that because you gave your
neighbor a milkweed you can peek over
the fence and make sure if you planted
it or not that's true that's true have
you done that
uh not yet but um
I'll text him
that's good because he needs to know he
needs to understand that uh
there are consequences to not complying
yeah I'm sure they'll be they'll be
great they've got two really key
daughters and they're you know they're
really sweet well I've had them in the
backyard too to see you know the
butterflies
well that's so that's so special mom
we're gonna we're gonna get all those
milkweeds out you know what I mean get
them out there
hello
cute it looks like Nala he looks like
Nala can you show him again
um it's it's a pitbull mix what is your
dog's name
Cosmo Cosmo
Cosmos resting I don't know I can turn
it around there's there's a few dogs
here yeah show us around a little bit
well because the let me see she's not
gonna be able to I don't know I want to
see it I want to see it I don't know if
you can see yeah just show us around
yeah just turn it around nice I love
that
you see Yep looks good there's Barbie
Barbie
[Laughter]
we got a whole
lot I see wow chaos
very cute dogs they're dogs hi hi
everybody
's busy chatting yeah yeah
great dog park because everybody here is
super nice Donna I have a bug question
okay have you heard of the spotted
lanternfly
I have not
they're very invasive bug and they hate
milkweed so milkweed actually poisons
this invasive species so that's good
just help the butterflies oh wow it
helps in the genocide of these Invader
yes and destroy crops oh no you
know I gotta tell you flies are are one
of the biggest enemies of of the
butterfly
adorable
you know when my job when when the dogs
go to the bathroom I mean every morning
noon and night I'm always checking to
make sure that everything is is clean
because the Flies are attracted to the
to the uh poop mom can I ask you a
question please
sure do you like my mustache and flavor
saver or Soul passion maybe is better
definitely better
you know I can't see you Ethan oh you
can't oh because of the wait when did
you cry you grew a mustache since the
last time I saw you well I just shaved
off my beard what do you guys think at
home
I don't like you with a mustache thank
you
I like you when you have like like a
two-day old you know beard thing going
on that looks good but um
I don't know
you've got you've got a nice like mouth
area and you shouldn't cover it up with
with your mustache well it's the same
it's the same length as my beard I just
cut the beard off
well I don't know it just kind of
reminds me of Doro or something Zorro
well your husband has the same facial
hair
no he doesn't he's got a full beard and
a mustache although I must admit dad
looks really good in a mustache because
he's got one of those big honking so so
basically your your mustache is it's
kind of beta and weak like if you had
like a more manly mustache well if my
lip was all up like my dad's then
it would make sense that looks better
yeah that looks better with the mustache
now you look better without a must you
and Sean Sean looks okay you know like
the goatee that he used to have but he
didn't have them all right
thank you Mom glad we were able to catch
uh connect today
Donna I think those ladies
if I if I feel absolutely that's why I
asked
don't take care I think those those
ladies are jealous of you because you're
prettier than them I I just want to say
that thank you baby yeah I I co-sign I
think they're a bunch of old ratty caddy
and the way you describe them
Donna they sound like real bees you know
oh no no no no
you know somebody's got to do something
about these monjong monsters I put the
group together and hopefully we don't
watch the show right
I hope not I know goes down when
the new card comes out I know that's the
new
okay I'll I'll pass along information
seriously consider that though before
your grandma's welfare before you pass
it to this this is a group of vultures
out here yeah no no no no no no maybe
he's got a group I can join with her I
don't know oh so you can bail on those
ladies yeah
I'm always up for upping my game
do any of them are they older or younger
than you
um I would say
they are
the same age or maybe a year or two
younger they're younger because I was
going to ask if they have any if you
guys have any life alerts there or
you're not old enough yet
life alerts oh absolutely fallen and I
can't well not for you not for you for
the other ladies
but they seem like they're in good shape
no
no where everybody's healthy
[Music]
yes hold on all right my mom said the
specific name of her friend so we gotta
cut that out but keep go tell me how
how sick she is
oh she doesn't take care of herself
sometimes she eats
um
sweets and things like that that she
really shouldn't with diabetes oh she
has diabetes
is it a weight thing or just a sugar
thing
I think it's a sugar thing when you've
got diabetes she's a healthy weight
though
well you know a lot of women my age
would probably say they could use a
blues
a few pounds right I mean I wouldn't say
that but
um I I say that a lot of women my age
probably would yeah
like to do that all right well uh thank
you Mom I wish you and your friends all
well good health on your show all of
your fans are are the best and they're
so supportive
you know in my my crazy butterfly stuff
everyone that's listening go out and buy
a milkweek plant and give it to a
neighbor and and and tell them that you
know you hope that they will do the same
all right let's get those milkweeds out
there
kill the Flies save the butterflies
and Ethan I'm gonna buy some for you
because you need to get going with that
let's go
this sounds like a children's book in
the making
but no the butterfly loved excuse me
hold on guys this is important hi I'm
Yuki Ethan you look so heck and good
with the mustache daddy as
respectfully love all the crew keep
kicking ass thank you girl
in response to Daddy as
Yuki daddy is your thoughts
you know what I think your fans
absolutely love you and Ethan if you
were they'd look past any physical
abnormalities they they just love you it
what you look like or anything well you
know what mom no they love you and with
that I will say Mom it's been such a joy
they enjoy this beautiful day with you
at the dog park We're Gonna Save the
butterflies
and guys if you do if you do if you do
the milkweed thing I guess share some
pictures we can share the positivity
right Grandma I mean oh yeah I call her
Grandma at home because I call Ela mom
I called your grandma though that's good
because sometimes I mix you guys up and
everyone gets confused
yeah you got to call me grandma it is
confusing okay Zach I'll be in touch
with you
you got it okay all right love you guys
bye bye
good thing oh hold on keep that
oh she she got out she got out okay wow
she figured that out wow real quick it's
a good thing we had the button here
because my mom straight up doxed her
friend's name and health
and also her own location and her own
physical her own location live
oh that's why we have the button love it
if we didn't have the button that
Mahjong group could have potentially be
ending I think it still might be you
think so you cannot Rock the Boat too
much if word gets out there's a lot of a
lot of tea spilled not phone call
we did kind of learn a lot about what
goes on there they ganging up on her and
it sounds like it's because it sounds
like a skill issue it sounds like
they're not good 100 that's what she she
didn't want to say it but that's what
yeah she's dunking on them and to the
extent that they feel like they so
threatened that they need to team up
against her for sure and she did at one
point say they're easy to put they're
easy yeah we heard that easy scrubs but
it's okay Mom you're good I mean
you know
don't hate the player hate the game
all right so there's uh my mom ladies
and gentlemen
Donna Klein
uh let's see what time is it two wait is
Jackal again 2 30.
okay
but seriously are we gonna go to the
Streamys because we should decide
well you're right we should decide we're
yeah we're going at the minimum you're
going no no no no no no no
are you going Dan
if I don't have coronavirus in three to
four days from now
you think that's responsible
yeah
uh okay so let's incubation period is
longer than that exposed
exposed Tuesday yesterday here let me
look it up what is isn't it like four to
for like three to five days something
like that I'll tell you right now
dude time from exposure to symptom onset
is thought to be 2 to 14 days bro two to
fourteen two to fourteen days well
that's quite a range isn't it
that's from Harvard health
what do they know
it says I'm seeing two to fourteen what
are you most contagious one to two days
before you feel sick that's exactly what
you guys were hanging out with right
right no I am aware that we we
definitely stepped in it with that so
um there's I don't think we can go I
don't think we can do it
I've been wearing a mask since you got
here it's just not enough it's just not
enough it's irresponsible no listen
because I'm not necessarily contagious
in fact it's very doubtful that I am
contagious but I've still been exposed
less than 24 hours ago
it's just not fair to put people at the
stream is through that
to be frank all memes aside
the only people that I think are
qualified to go to the streamings were
the ones that weren't here yesterday
which just happened to be bro you I
don't know how and how many ways I need
to tell you this I am not going without
the crew period
period
okay I'm going for you guys
y'all guilted me
peer pressured me
but you're not going I'm not going but
it's not by choice we all want to go
we're disappointed that we can't go I
know you me too dude I'm gutted I'm
absolutely gutted that I can't go to the
Streamys
yeah let me call Ela and see if she
thinks
because we really do need to decide
because there's a lot of people on the
on the line here this is a girl him
hey uh I'm live can you talk I I was
just listening live okay okay so you
have the um context
all right so I don't
yeah so I don't we're just saying we
need to decide if we're if we're gonna
go because there's lots of people that
that are
will need to be notified
okay so everybody on the cruise just
been exposed to covid
oh we don't know yet if they and got it
or not but the incubation period is 2 to
was like hardcore positive thick dark
black line and y'all were with them all
day yesterday no no no not all day three
hours three hours is enough man might as
well have been all day
um I haven't seen them but yes you're
talking about the crew they were all
there with him for three hours yesterday
when he was in that dark black and
that's the most contagious part
Ethan has not been exposed
probably like a day or two where we'll
start seeing their
their covet tests either positive or not
but it takes up to 14 days do you want
to be responsible for a for a a mega
event super spreader event at the
Streamys I couldn't live with that I
could I just couldn't live with that on
my conscience
yeah you also can't live with leaving
the house on your conscience
got him no no listen I'm telling you I
really just been totally gutted by this
actually it's not up to me it's the
disease
yeah I told them
you guys went at 10 pm and you got home
at two dude you got home at 2 A.M
[Applause]
watching shows okay
[Music]
so I need to talk to somebody else
because you're like not objective let me
let me talk to you
no you can't touch my phone bro I want
to talk to ELA
if Dan touches my phone I definitely
can't go
God damn it but don't you think God is
trying to send us a message in the sense
that
our vacation day was on that day also
hold on
God but like the universe
because not only did our vacation was on
that day
that was a tragic and frankly uh
right I wonder if we okay and then
Hassan was wearing a clearance Klein
water shirt on Monday
okay and then a b and Lena they come in
who've never had kovid okay these guys
have perfect immune systems
they come in
black strips straight the across
[Music]
[Applause]
it doesn't matter I'm saying here talk
to it Dan talk to Dan
you guys aren't won't listen to reason
God did
Halo so here's the thing
here's the thing oh Dan hold the speaker
right on okay I'll hold it right on here
so here's the thing is that
um
you know unfortunately yes the crew was
most likely exposed a b was likely very
contagious yesterday
um however
Ethan wasn't here and neither were you I
don't care I'm not going without you
guys
well what I'm saying is I even if we
can't go I think you and Ethan should
still go
opinion Dan you see Eli he's supporting
my theory won't go if the whole Crow
isn't going yes I'm not trying to roll
there just I thought I needed a click so
that if it went down I had a whole gang
to back me up like Gangs of New York
they're gonna sit us with the crit with
the moist critical look-alikes
bro you have we have like 12 tickets why
don't you just invite uh your like
invite Donna Don and Gary can go no they
have IDs they're not even gonna let them
in
they are the only one going don't don't
sit us in some random table and that
might become really deadly well just
fine that's not a gamble we can think
just don't tell them she's right just
don't tell us what sit at an empty seat
a whole empty we'll have ten no shows so
Dan is supporting me though Ila if
you're listening between the lines
no because you're saying the crew is not
going which Visa b means listen I'm not
going and Eli's not going listen you're
making a point with like the incubation
period yeah well are you going are you
going I mean I I there's a lot of
pressure right now okay I I I don't know
okay to go or not to go
I mean I personally want to go I know
you have right I know in this moment I
feel fine but I logically know that
there's a decent chance that I might get
Corona in the next couple days right so
I'm just being realistic here is that I
might not be able to go so if
let's say Sunday morning
you don't feel sick
and sitting meme from the subreddit that
we looked at yeah
dude we'll get clowned on
forever me and Ila alone at a table
people like yo they nobody want to sit
with them okay yeah so everyone should
come we're like the blood we're like the
lame kids at lunch in the front row
[Laughter]
uh that makes me want to see you go even
more to be honest that sounds awesome
so if Sunday comes around you test
negative in the morning and you don't
feel sick
um
then yeah I mean I guess I would lean
towards going maybe I'd wear masks do
you think it's really fair to the
streamies who put who is such a
reputable such a well-established uh uh
Society
to to not tell them that there's a
chance I might not go so that they can
fill that table it's just not fair to
our friends at the streamies
to to be like oh maybe I'll go maybe I'm
not I mean they have a show to run right
it's just not fair
to tell them
it's a little unfair I guess and you
know because you're in the event
planning you know what on the set all of
a sudden on the day of course I don't
want to expose much people to Corona
obviously don't want to be that guy yeah
and our good friends at the Streamys who
are been nothing but gracious super
authentic always choosing the best
winners
[Applause]
do you have something to say cam
oh thank you
oh nice so I think I made a compelling
point about not being fair to the
Streamys
I mean it's only a point because you're
get out of here I thought you're
spraying me spray him cam oh open your
mouth then oh get out of here having a
gun held to you it's like it just feels
wrong get out of here okay well Dan oh
what are you the rest of you guys feel
uh Zach how do you feel about it
ah
I mean I could take it or leave it to be
honest with you Sonic's not the right
person to okay preference aside what's
the right thing to do
[Music]
here's the thing there's a lot of people
that do want to go so I feel those who
do want to go should go and if you don't
and you're feeling a little iffy on it
then you know
you don't have to go
it's a good point so everybody has an
out but me
but you are the ones that peer pressure
me into this
to go like this we didn't know we didn't
know Olivia bought three dresses
said Ethan please respect the lives of
others
I swear to God I just read that that's
very scary
already are out by the way I think Lena
and ab are for sure not but what's your
thoughts Lena on on what the morally
right thing to do here for the streamies
uh it's an institution we deeply care
about
I don't know I can't speak on that I
just feel so bad because we're ruining
it potentially for everyone but I also
got like four different dresses and you
know I was really invested in this well
if everyone who got a nice outfit we can
go do something Posh together a
different thing where we can all dress
up
but Lena what's the right thing to do
what is the right thing to do tell me
well I just know for me and Amy we can
go that would be the right thing to do
um and what about for Dan who was
exposed
I think that if there I mean I need to
do more research I I can't speak my
client uh is not at Liberty to speak at
this time okay so nobody has an opinion
Olivia Ian opinions
I think we should talk about this later
[Music]
I'm worried that
um that we don't know enough right now
talking about like
who's gonna go who's not going to go
because are they even gonna let us go if
you guys don't go
no I don't think so right but no I think
maybe but you're going to now you're
going without me
well you seem like the person who
doesn't want to go the most if I don't
go you'll go
no I I don't know sure yeah I mean I
would like to still go
without me there's a lot of people that
do I miss you exponentially but I would
still like to attend I know Sam really
wants to go and she was not at the
office yesterday
Ethan Ela
uh Sam and Zach that's that's the squad
Zach you weren't even there yesterday
you said that they're at home like he's
in quarantine and
maybe we I was around
I was around everyone and that's just
enough brother what does that mean he
wrote the wrong people well he was
around this morning but AB was only here
for like 45 minutes
there was crossover a little bit I gave
Zach a fist bump a fist bump of death
yeah we also kiss each other
all right so I guess the only thing left
to do is a poll
now guys I need to tell you what we're
considering here
maybe maybe we should I would suggest we
should look at the CDC guidelines for
this current strain
and not convince the audience that if
anybody goes they're basically murderers
which I assume is what you're about to
say I'm not saying maybe we should look
into it no what I was gonna say
is this vote
you should reflect morally what you
think is the right thing to do if you
think I should go but like what's the
right thing to do for The streamies Who
again before you make that moral pull we
should figure out what the
CDC guidelines are for this strain okay
CDC 2023 we'll do it right now I mean
what the hell yeah I think it's
important and I know there's a lot I
know Sam really wants to go me too bro
got it oh shut up
I'm absolutely devastated I know Olivia
really wants to go through look it's not
about want okay we're doing the right
thing here
okay here I pulled up the uh 2013 2023
covid
uh incubation period okay well the poll
results are in we're going
okay well hold on we didn't even finish
are you putting it up on screen
we didn't even finish our research well
the poll is Trump's any research
but we didn't finish our research
yeah you can hang up now Ethan said yeah
could somebody do this who's uh who
uh
okay sounds good thanks
if you were exposed here we go here we
go
all right here we go guys if you were
exposed to the virus
here are the steps you should take
regardless of vaccine vaccination status
like opening random photos or if you've
been previously affected
okay this is CDS this is CDC whatever
they say is what we do okay
time it's fraction time baby day Zero is
the day of your last exposure to someone
so that day Zero was yesterday wow I
mean technically I guess it would be
today right right it would be today
because a b was here and so was Lena yes
and a brief period of time and uh Abe
licht's Zack's hand I don't think that
actually thank you but yeah
okay so today is is uh Ground Zero got
it day one is tomorrow first full day
after exposure
it says here you can still develop covid
10 days after your exposure take
precautions wear a mask yada yada wear a
mask do not go to places where you're
unable to wear a mask
I think I don't think they'd eject to us
wearing masks watch for a fever
obviously
it says day six get tested at least five
full days after your last exposure
test even
excuse me God damn said donut sorry
I'm fine
might be a symptom of it I don't know
day six
if you test negative continue uh through
day 10. if you test positive well
obviously
after a negative test
uh
Master not rec it doesn't really say
what to do
it says just wear a mask I guess or
don't go to places where you can't wear
masks
going around it says wear a High's mask
open be careful
it says
wear a mask
or respirator anytime you run others
inside your home or indoors in public
sounds like CDC says that we can go
but if you all start getting sick then
we're out
how about that
I guess it's fair yeah that's fair that
makes sense yeah yeah okay
so we're gonna keep on uh planning to go
unless you all start getting uh start
getting sick
but again
this is where we have to keep in mind
our dear deer streamies that
there's a chance that some of y'all
might get sick and we might not go I
mean then they're gonna have a big empty
table to deal with on the last minute
and Dan you agreed with me that that's a
little unfair to the streamies
um I'm sure they can I mean yeah can we
tell them maybe we should just tell them
like hey we had an exposure event we're
planning on coming still but just so you
know there's a chance that we might all
get coveted and have to bail
yeah that would be fair that's a fair
that's a fair thing because again
that's the least we can do for them
you know
yeah I would hate to get matpat sick oh
God
he grants people Grace you'd be like
when Donald Trump tried to give Biden
kovid at the debate
[Music]
yeah I like my coffee dark
all right so we're planning on going
but we have to notify the streamies
it's a big deal
Ethan stopped trying to get out of it
listen I'm just trying to do the right
thing
that's it that's all I've ever tried to
do that's just the Story of My Life
Ethan he's just trying to do the right
thing nothing less nothing more
I did everything right and they indicted
me that's you guys right now y'all still
indicting my ass
all right so I'm gonna tell
um
I gotta tell uh our person okay I'm
saying he love voice nope
okay all right well you're watching
right she's watching yeah so Ela you
gotta uh
tell your folks to let the Streamys know
that we had a mass
a mass exposure events
and we're still planning on coming if
we're not if we don't fall sick
after our Mass exposure event
we all don't fall ill yeah and die Jay
Shetty is definitely behind this
did you possibly run into Jay Shetty at
all uh uh did you cross paths with Jay
Shetty or an associate of his with
beautiful eyes Abe
and possibly possibly I saw someone in
the dark in one of the rides with very
beautiful blue eyes might have been him
oh my God
yo is this real chat
yo what the what yo this can't be
real nah surely not chat is this real
Jay Shetty man this guy does have a lot
of friends in weird places no I'm
kidding this is this is Photoshop
I wouldn't even do shitty that dirty
it's from Ryan or Harvey too right yeah
it is it's Harvey oh what who is this
with though
it's with probably like Elon Musk or
some
what the original photo yeah I I don't
know I don't no there's no photo of them
together because that would be all over
the place
there's the photo of him with uh OG Lane
Elaine
so there it is uh
I'm gonna did you hear
what I said all right let's move on
wow
thrilling stuff here high high stakes
game we play Jack will be calling in in
about 10 minutes
um so perhaps just some of these uh
Goofs and gaffs something quick
what's chicken katsu it's like shaking
Curry
fried chicken curry
yeah sounds hella good yeah it's pretty
good wait wait they put the fried
chicken in the curry doesn't get soggy
no fried cheese
crunchy stuff it's awesome dude yeah
it's from this place it was really good
but I'm not gonna stay in there is it
Japanese food what kind of food is that
it looks like a Japanese yeah it is is
that right
let me take a look at this
Japan is all about the respect it's all
about the costume
wagyu hamburger man that ain't no wagyu
why do people why do they do that they
go it's wagyu it's like what
that cost like 500 per ounce
surely they're saving selling that at a
whole restaurant
Osco's got a good deal on him right now
um Costco yeah it's like but it's super
expensive right it's like a hundred
bucks I think for like
five ounces or something like that yeah
wow they have really a wagyu hamburger
yo you wanna try it
I'm thinking I want something with more
vegetables is there vegetables we gotta
Grill veggie option
this doesn't this looks like a pretty
like there's a grilled veggie this looks
like a constipation meal too yeah it's
it's I'm gonna skip I'm gonna skip thank
you though you're missing out dude yeah
[Music]
um
I've never tried katsu though oh on
me yo what the hold on
hold on
I gotta skip this stuff guys I gotta
keep my together all right
all right let's see we got all kinds of
stuff to watch
Tim Poole for example
oh this is actually right on point
absolutely I guess there's a conspiracy
amongst conservatives that
based on nothing that Biden's planning
another lockdown is that what this is in
reference to it has to be right
believe it or not and you probably find
this easy to believe because it is Tim
pool it's way stupider than that
really yeah
I'm trying to I'm trying to remove brain
cells and come up with a new thing I
wouldn't watch the the beginning of the
segment to see what set this all off but
uh let's watch the clip first and then
I'll explain all right what we're so
upset about this is his friend who said
uh he said in a thousand years we'll
look back
and think man it's crazy that people
were not accepting the gospel that's
what he said right
or if that was him to tell you it was
him no it was him also he's wearing a
blue velvet jacket it sure is I'm not
sure about Olivia and I were talking
about that earlier like the the whole
outfit choices
what's that horror movie by uh is it
blue velvet yeah this man is wearing a
blue velvet jacket David Lynch literally
made a video a movie about how creepy it
is
couldn't be an uglier shade of blue also
could not be uglier
all right here we go also blue mask blue
velvet yeah
here we go that that is the recipe to
destroy your country is to shut it down
don't do that again and don't make
people but dirty masks on
nice I'm sick of it man I'm sick
of it I will not do it again
bro just change your mask man
is Tim not handing out new math at the
office or what they don't need to be
dirty yeah yeah it's easy you know you
just you just change them regularly my
brother my man's broken or brush your
teeth yeah that helps too that big time
helps wash your face
mm-hmm
I love how angry he is bro what are you
doing like that you cannot be that angry
about Mass it's got to be something else
going on
it's that what it's it's the lockdowns
in particular the lockdowns that they
were really focusing on you know who we
need in in charge of like public health
policy this guy
got the credentials he knows everything
he's got the jacket he's got the jacket
here is the context which I'm dying to
find out here
let's see
uh this is just a longer this isn't the
actual full context so this is just in
case you wanted to watch more Beyond
where it cuts off there
just look at this guy man
like and I'm not even trying to say
anything
but just look at this dude
kind of looks like me
no it doesn't
that's Mega brain Dan I guess maybe is
that unedited
his face yeah bro that's what happens
when you're from Arkansas and you live
in the same trailer next to your sister
what the hell bro's built like an app
game that's crazy built like a what an
app game
no it doesn't make sense it doesn't make
sense that's why I asked to clarify yeah
all right enough for that one yeah I'll
tell you what this guy knows how to bail
hay that's all I said
you know anything about him this man he
could be arguing against the other guy
in this clip you don't even watched it
yet yeah right dude look at him it looks
like when a cartoon takes drugs you know
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
taking that out oh no all right let's
watch what
it's gonna be you're going to hurt me
that's that's and that's always what the
what the case was when it came to the
people that were like oh you know you're
not wearing your mask it's always like
you should be wearing your mask because
you're gonna hurt me oh here no Arkansas
accent I uh I'm he's like did you like
that argument he's like should I be
embarrassed or did you like that look at
this face he made
they're not going to give the benefit of
the doubt anymore yeah 15 days to smoke
as soon as someone says something about
oh why aren't you wearing your mask
Something's Gonna Be Like because I want
to get you know whatever they're gonna
just you know give a bunch of lip and
it's gonna be a lot of Confrontation
I've got a feeling the people and not
all of them but for the most part if
people are scared into wearing masks by
TV shows those are those are cowardly
people that's that's a behavior of
cowards and cowards aren't very likely
to come out on the street and challenge
you for not wearing a mask they
absolutely if there's if they're God
what is this weird tough guy
nobody's saying anything to you they're
like already fantasizing about dumb Libs
telling me to put my mask on I'll tell
you what man these cowards went and dare
it's like what the first of all
there's no shutdown
okay
that's scenario a that's not happening
right
scenario B there's you're nobody's
telling you to wear a mask
please take off your mask not yet I mean
it's weird these guys are you're mad
he's making me uncomfortable
uh here's the article they're popping
off about let's see this is what I was
real curious about
a summer surge of new covid Burien
should we be wearing masks the New York
Post actually so here's the thing
they never actually Tim just pulls this
article up and just shows the headline
that's and that's what they're
discussing I I pulled a few quotes in
the dock if you want to take a look of
what is actually said in this article
that they're so upset about it says
recent data from New York Department of
Health uh August 2nd showed covet cases
spiked 55 over prior week with an
average of 824 reported cases per day
across the state that's very low
that's and continue reading that's sick
that's really low
the rise of covid-19 cases isn't limited
to New York the CDC reported 10 000 U.S
Hospital admissions for kova 19 in the
week ending August 5th 14 uh percent
increase however despite alarmist
headlines about a summer surge many
doctors are urging people not to Panic
it's funny that it's almost self-aware
yeah they go despite articles like this
right and that's the thing that's
alarmist headlines that whole segment
and him freaking out is them being
alarmist about a headline without
reading the article that says exactly
that that there's no reason to panic
the Mandate they're freaking out about
right and seeing the whole College in
Atlanta doing a 14-day mask requirement
yeah so they they pulled up another
article and I looked into it and it's
one college in Atlanta has had a bunch
of students get coveted in the last
couple weeks like a big spike and so
they asked the students to start wearing
masks holy this one notepad
thing
yeah this is this is what we're having a
nervous breakdown about
I love that for them
they're the best man they're so good
awesome yeah they're the best
um so there you go
one more time for blue velvet
the recipe to destroy your country is to
shut it down don't do that again and
don't make people put dirty
masks on hold on wait I have an idea to
make this better okay
hold on what is the dirty mask thing bro
like I don't know what mask you put on
your face but
they're disposable
exactly that's that's it here
uh I don't know if this is good but I'm
gonna try it
that that is the recipe to destroy your
country is to shut it down don't do that
again and don't make people for
dirty masks son
nice I'm sick of it man I'm sick
of it I will not do it again
that that is the recipe to destroy your
country is to shut it down don't do that
again and don't make people put
dirty man I'll be I'll bring I'll be
thinking crutches I'm gonna be armed but
I tell you man I'll beg someone come
tell me put my mask on I'm armed ready
to kill brother
uh Goofs and gaffs uh actually Jack uh
just joined the lobby
or let's talk to Jack about the uh
Sniper Wolf business let's talk to
Jack's films yes and then we'll get back
we'll talk about fresh and Fit I think
I'll touch on fousey a bit you know I
don't want to talk about it too much
but I do want to say one small thing
about it and all kinds of fun Goofs and
gaffes as well so let's say hello to a
friend of the show
love his icon on Zoom here
um long time friend of the show
damn you guys really killed me in the
poll 83 said yes
that we should go to the streamings
yeah that's that is like a shutout
that's a shut up oh there is
oh my goodness what's going on gang
thank you there you are on the uh the
set the the beautiful uh react set it's
so nice to see it in person wow
thrilling here I am in the flesh so um
first of all nice to see you nice to
hear from you friend of the show Jack
films
otherwise it's I think it's been since
January 2020.
since uh last time I saw I was saw you I
was at your house and uh Chocolate Rain
guy was there and he was talking to me
about his homemade that takes kratom
um it must have been but like yeah 2020
at the very latest that that could have
happened
um uh that's really funny that you
mentioned that Aaron and I talk about
that every now and then what the the
Kratom thing
that's a wild drug in it do people still
take that I know that like it's like a
it's like a mild opiate that isn't
hasn't been uh
there's no laws about it so people can
just buy it from like head shops or
online and scares the Christ out of me I
was offered a sponsorship
um oh a while back to do it and I I
turned it down because I was like I
don't know about that yeah it doesn't
seem like a uh I was trying to sponsor
you bro that's weird I mean I I guess I
guess they were but it was just one of
those like I don't know okay guys have
you ever wanted to get high
honestly but you can't find a drug
dealer right it's like I'll just I'll
stick to gambling let's do the gambling
sponsors that's fine right yeah those
are good so congratulations on the
success of your channel I mean you are
what I checked the other day you're at
like 10 million views for the month
that's phenomenal oh my goodness thank
you very much it's weird man it's very
weird oh thank you no it's just one of
those like
didn't expect that to happen right um at
all because it's just a new form of
posting I suppose but it's really cool
seeing
um just kind of this like this movement
this the viewers are really getting into
it yeah and that I find that highly
encouraging and like really it's like
thank God because beforehand I just I
felt like I was the
I was was I insane you know like am I
the insane person here
um but people are like saying like no
wait this is kind of up so that
that helps big time it's cool to see and
do you think that
having this community of engaged people
is going to make a difference or
does she not care I mean she's making so
much money no of course she doesn't why
should she care
I sure I don't know I really don't know
I don't know I don't want to be entirely
too naive I don't want to be entirely
too pessimistic right because I do feel
like we're kind of on the cusp of some
movement some like because more and more
people more creators are talking about
this like oompaville made a video about
it and um uh cinnamon toast Ken talked
about like more people are talking about
sniperwolf's children yeah I have
mentioned it and you mentioned it
obviously right sorry yeah I didn't mean
to ignore you by the way I took your
advice because I made another main
Channel video and I got rid of the pop
filter
um oh I don't know if you oh let me let
me hear the before and after
okay the different mic I'm using now is
different Mike so okay but like the the
p's don't come out as hard so like
that's kind of pretty cool yeah yeah on
that mic I can see that uh it would make
a difference but
yeah this is the yeah can you just hold
that up during the interview please yeah
yeah for sure for sure here we go uh
yeah anyways how you been man it's been
a minute it's been good you know just
doing like Dad stuff
having another boy that's basically it
you know congratulations thanks finally
congratulate you that's freaking awesome
man thank you so much
and um that's about it you know but I do
think like even if ultimately
something doesn't happen like tangible
it is good
that people are ridiculing her
frankly well it's just it's just they're
they're taking they're taking notes
they're taking notice of like they see
the signs and that's what I'm really
trying to do over on that JoJo Jackson's
Channel like yeah we make a whole bingo
game out of it but like I show them the
signs of like freebooting and people are
picking up on it really quickly and just
all the very predictable things
sniperwolf says and does and doesn't say
and doesn't do
um so it's it's
it's more about just like teaching
people like why this is up why
this isn't okay why this shouldn't be
okay and why this shouldn't be
normalized because one of the whole main
reasons that
um I've been making these videos on
sniperwolf is just that she's being
bolstered and supported by YouTube and
platform by YouTube and Vidcon and that
that screams like hey it's normalized
now and that's where I kind of want to
come in and say I I that's not okay with
this I don't like that that's a really
good point
um
about
um the YouTube supporting her because I
yeah they have were tweeting out her
videos giving her shout outs
and it's weird to me because what
she was a keynote speaker at VidCon
wasn't that sure was which is like okay
weird like about inserting tick tocks
without a comment like cool
um but what's weird to me and you I know
you've been around forever so you
remember this
there was a time
like five to ten years ago when this
meta started to crop up of these super
lazy reactions of like Jax you remember
this guy he was like super popular he
was blowing up doing basically exactly
what sniper uh wolf and xqc do she does
on her YouTube channel
Jinx what did I say
yeah Jinx yes don't you remember him
that guy was just remember it in now he
fell off Gene but no Jing's for sure and
so everybody though just everybody came
at this guy Jinx everybody was in you
know Unison like this is up this
guy sucks and you know he was forced to
stop
and somehow in the mix
and I think this is probably because of
twitch's influence
that has completely normalized this
where it's like
there's there's streamers that people
like that they're cool you know like xqc
even like my co-host Hassan you know uh
when they stream they
they do not
transform the content
but the problem is and Hassan doesn't do
this where xqc does he posted wholesale
on his channel and so people become
desensitized to it they think it's okay
and that's why we're seeing more people
like sniper it's just it's become
completely normalized where before you
couldn't really get away with this I
just find that really odd no that's a
really excellent point twitch 100 has
helped normalize that and I will say
like I don't want people to think that
I'm against all reaction content like no
I think there's a right way to do
reaction content and there's a wrong way
to do it
but twitch's absolutely helps normalize
the wrong way to do it when you post the
whole the whole vods without any editing
you know yeah and just that's when it
gets scummy just to be clear I'm not
saying that what they do on Twitch is
wrong
I'm saying what they do on YouTube is
yeah
um yeah I can get behind that I yeah I
know what you're saying because I don't
know I feel like the issue of of usage
on Twitch is more nuanced
well if you're if you're reacting to
something on Twitch you do have to watch
it without comment to absorb it you do
have to like have time to process what
you're seeing you can't you know react
all the time but when you have that
edited video on YouTube on a different
platform where it's a VOD and not a live
stream that's when you really gotta I do
feel like there's some kind of
obligation to trim it up in such a way
where it becomes more transformative it
should be more complementary to the
source material these reactions like I
do feel like you should kind of have to
have seen the original material first
before you can enjoy
um I don't know maybe maybe people
disagree with me on this and I I don't
know if there's like a total answer for
for all examples but I feel like
reaction content should generally be
complementary
um to the source material where you kind
of have to see the source material first
so then you can appreciate other
people's reactions and I don't know if
that's like a hot take or not but that's
that's kind of what I think I think
there are some um examples where you
don't need it's criticism then you don't
need to watch the original
because yeah people come and watch your
video because to criticize the other one
so the purpose of the two videos is
completely different
it's about like uh part part of it is
supplanting the originals Market where
you're stealing views from the original
but if they're coming to watch someone
criticize them it's it's fair to assume
or it's fair to say they're in different
markets so I don't think I I mean but
but ultimately I mean
the problem is
she when I watched her videos she
literally just describing what's
happening
I mean it's odd
so here's the the other reason that I
keep
talking about making videos on
sniperwolf is the rabbit hole just keeps
getting deeper so like the first main
Channel video I made about her was
largely about like how
non-transformative
um her commentary is how it's just
summarizing like you said what what was
happening that was like one of my chief
points in the first video but the latest
video that I uploaded a week ago
it was more into like oh wait no she's
just outright stealing whole ass
tick tocks without any commentary like
forget like not even freebooting
metaphorically but actually literally
free booting and I showed I showed a few
examples where she just
play someone else's Tick Tock without
any reaction there's not even a face cam
and then moves on to the next Tick Tock
reaction and it's like wait a minute
what was I said at the top of the show
didn't we Dan
we watched it before we went live okay
so let me have an example of that in the
dock yeah I I see you did this in this
she forgot and I was it's great I mean
it really shows how how nutso this is
I'm gonna uh yeah I'm just pulling up
the timestamp
so here's an example of what Jack is
talking about here everyone might make
you angry because it sure made me angry
so there I was hosting yet another Bubba
Bingo stream when all of a sudden I'm
surprised with this word it's just a
sniperwolf go
why isn't she taking up two-thirds of
the frame like she always does you know
so we could see her insightful
commentary and her epic reactions so we
continue watching The Tick Tock by
popular Creator Tony stotopsy link below
if you want to watch more of their stuff
and we're all trying to predict what
sniperwolf will say how she'll react Etc
here's my real-time reaction to what
happens next
she played the entire Tick Tock without
a video of her even on it
she was not there it was just a
re-upload so here
which is
pretty fantastic Sam I think you
forgotten something
she had to live she forgot to react
that's right everyone she forgot to
react I mean someone else's Tick Tock in
its entirety but didn't provide an ounce
of commentary I I find it just like if
you're in the business where you can
forget to react
the format is questionable
yeah this is by the way like we find two
other examples of her doing the exact
same thing so it's not like oh maybe it
was an editing error no no it was a
deliberate choice so you think that
she's like this is a funny Tick Tock I'm
gonna include it even though I have
nothing to say about it yeah I think she
does that to like and I sorry for
quoting my own video but I think it's
like she's using it as a bumper for her
own little variety show you know what I
mean like it's just one of those oh it
fits the theme of all these tick tocks
I've curated so I may I'll just play it
you know in its entirety
um I don't need to react to that one
it's just a bumper it's just a little
transitional piece before we get to my
next epic reaction like that's what that
is you know the thing that really got me
going was just how mean and rude she was
to you for no reason and just
you know that that really set me off a
little bit on her that uh
she's like so arrogant and cocky about
her content like being so good I just at
least if you're doing this have a little
humility you know what I mean
just be like yeah you know I'm getting
it's awesome people watch this I
don't know why but here we are
not to speculate too much on our
character but I doubt humility is one of
her top traits
um but no she's she's great
um but
yeah yeah we're just we're having a lot
of fun let me ask you a hard question
because I know YouTube has a history of
getting involved in these types of
things
I wonder if the harassment Clause is
something you should be worried about
because I know that previously that has
become a problem when people have hyper
focused on specific creators creators
have you heard from YouTube are you
worried about that
I've not heard from YouTube I'm not
terribly worried about it because what I
do
on that channel and the on the main
channel the videos like I really would
not consider it harassment bullying
like
she's she's the one who's pretty good at
that she's pretty good the whole
bullying people for their looks and all
that stuff or loads of examples of that
but like I don't do that like when I
stream I
I don't talk about looks appearances
none of that my criticisms are purely on
the content of her reactions and I don't
think I really strongly don't think
that's harassment that's bullying it's
not it's just I just like I said the
rabbit hole keeps getting deeper that's
how I continue like that's how I'm able
to keep making videos on that channel
because I do all of these like just live
reacting to her reactions without having
screened any of her videos
and throughout these streams we just
keep finding like worse stuff she's done
like we're not going back in the
archives of like all the years she's
been doing this we're looking at like
yesterday's video last week's video
today's video she's continuously
repeatedly and blatantly doing all of
these things and I'm just calling her
out for it I'm not like it doesn't turn
into like like
schoolyard bullying where I'm like go
get wait no look look at what
she just did do you guys catch that you
know she did this or she didn't do that
or she spent 40 seconds not reacting at
all and left it all in there or you know
she repeated this the same clip and her
same reaction twice in the same video so
I don't think that's harassment it's
just like it's not I agree it's not
harassment and the way you're doing it
is really
the right way to do it you're talking
about the content not about like like
you said the her physical attributes and
stuff like that
but I
I hope that you know YouTube sees it
that way too I do and I mean if you
haven't heard anything from them that's
a good that's a good thing
I can't imagine that she's not
complaining uh to somebody there about
it
no absolutely but like at the same time
like
I was looking up like other vid like
before I made my first main Channel
video on the whole
sniperwolf
um situation I was looking at like
videos other creators had made you know
and half of them were just like
hella misogynistic and it right just
like to stop that like that doesn't help
your case that just makes her case
stronger when you attack her like people
only watch her because she's a
chick and it's like shut the up
that's not like I hate that because
that's not true and a mild argument
people don't don't even watch her
channel for her they watch it for the
tick tocks and the proof is when she
doesn't even react like literally she's
not there and they like it it has
nothing to do with like oh I just love
sniper's Channel because you know she's
a great reactor I watch them for her
absolutely not so no I I'm not playing
that game so that's why I'm not terribly
concerned about the whole harassment
class that's coming down on me that's
really good because my one of my First
Reactions was because the same thing I
know that it's like the go home gamer
girl thing like any of these top women
streamers are the target of so much
misogyny and just stupid crap like that
but the way you're doing it is so the
right way to do it and I don't think
anyone could ever ever level that
against you maybe Trisha Paytas
who hates you by the way did I ever did
I appreciate you about that
have we met I don't know but did we ever
talk about that that she kept she had
she hates you yeah she she does we
talked a little bit
um
uh a couple of times
um years ago but like we talked on the
show about it no no never on the show
backyard party somewhere yeah no so the
thing is like that is it's so weird
because
I've never like I have zero history with
her I've never said like anything to her
except like how do you do like hello
like in passing like on the set of a
Shane Dawson music video 10 years ago
and then again at uh one of the shorty
Streamys one of the award shows
years ago are you going to that by
the way no I didn't get an invite what
the see I'm not good we have a
bunch of extra tickets Jack I'm not good
if you'd like to go
um we just found out today that we have
several extra tickets oh that's tempting
no that's that's very tempting I'm not
going because if Jack is not invited
that's oh thank you
what a pal what a Chum
sorry for that tangent but um yeah so
you haven't you never said anything to
her no that's the thing I've never been
like
like never never and I always
you're such a nice guy and that's what I
always told her I was like there's no
shot that Jack did any of this I have a
theory that she hates my guts because I
didn't talk to her at the streaming
shorties whatever it was back in 2018
um where we all said we were all sat at
the same table
and like I I guess I didn't talk to her
because I didn't really I'm sorry I
didn't want to talk to her I there it is
I don't know like what I don't have
anything to say to you there it is no
because this is beyond a theory that you
know what I mean this is the incident
that Trisha told us about all those
years ago so was that the I I didn't
remember what it was but I remember her
saying at an award show and Jack
didn't talk to me so that's it so it
wasn't something I said it was what I
didn't say that spoke volumes okay she I
think there's a part of her that
genuinely thinks
that all the men around her should be
trying to her and if there isn't
then they're being mean I don't know is
that possible well you know what I'm not
gonna comment on that particular Theory
but I as you're talking about this I
actually remember didn't we
didn't didn't somebody on our subreddit
post some receipts that she was a Jax
films fan at one point oh yeah she was
she used to tweet at you it was
uncovered on the subreddit yeah she was
like no it's Jack Jack's films so she
she was a big fan and she didn't she
didn't get the recognition she felt like
you were
not wanting to talk to her which is as
you know
uh big crime against humanity the
cardinal sin yeah I'm I'm sorry Trisha
Paytas I didn't want to talk to you
that you know was there a reason you
didn't want to talk to her you just
didn't know anything about her
um I I don't know I just
just a shady like just the Shady stuff
she's been a part of like I just don't
really want to like get involved in that
so that's why I didn't that's why I
chose not to talk to her so she already
had a reputation I didn't know
uh I don't know what year it was was
that like post chicken nugget stuff
okay I don't know what the chicken
nugget incident yeah this is 2018. this
is like this is uh oh my God May of 2018
nope April 2018 sorry
2018. let me just say when people say
why are you talking about Trisha
Jack was the subject of deep persistent
defamation at her hands the man deserves
to have a platform to defend himself
the whole thing's just so weird
it's like well like where's this hate
coming from because I remember she must
have picked up that you didn't that you
didn't care for her I guess which is
fair right and that's not a hatred like
I don't hate like of course I I have no
hatred I wish you know ill will I just
didn't want to talk to you is that a
crime no of course and of course not and
she should mess me up listen as a
controversial person myself when people
don't want to associate with me I
totally get it you know what I mean like
okay no way yeah there's a reason I've
got this here okay
[Laughter]
um but this is interesting because yeah
she was tweeting at you from 2012 who
wants to be my next music video me
please she said
the the previous Link in the Discord
Ethan is even uh even more telling but
the uh yeah this one you just pulled up
yeah uh Hey YouTube gals who would like
to be the girl my upcoming dubstep
solves everything me I'm your biggest
fan Jackie
seriously though she's your biggest fan
dude well how about that no again no ill
will at all let me debug this uh uh
deconstruct this 2018 what was the
Trisha controversy then
um I think it was the chicken nugget
thing isn't that when we met her 28 no
that was like already history when we
met was it 2019. oh but she she had the
the this is so the multiple personality
thing she had the trans thing she had
the chicken nugget thing I mean she was
getting a lot of grief at that that was
her thing I mean she that was her thing
controversial yeah
um sure it is she was with the Vlog
Squad a lot too right maybe they have
beef with Jack do you beef with the blog
Squad not not at all but that's where I
was I was seated with I want to say the
Vlog Squad at the shorty Awards in April
of 2018. that would make sense because
she right right yeah
she was with them at the time okay
I see what happened it was a very random
seating arrangement like I you know I I
knew of David dobrik and and some of the
you know the the pals that He piled
around with but I didn't really know
very much but it was just one that was
like oh I guess I'm seated at this table
what up hello
I see what happened and she she just
really held a grudge so there it is
Jackson films is innocent I have said
from day one he's a sweet man he is not
a misogynist in any sense the accusation
itself is absurd on face this man he's a
man of the people he's a man of all
genders of people all walks of life
right all creatures on this Earth he's a
vegan
uh 100 he's vegan I don't touch the
stuff the man he's a saint practically
literally you can say literally not
practice he is literally a saint there
it is and that that's that
so um well I'm just very I'm so happy
for you uh and the success of this
channel I think it's brilliant my
favorite part thanks buddy is that you
take her non-transformative content and
then you totally transform it so hers is
not fair use but you're sure as is
that is the goal honestly to make it
like something greater than itself like
greater than some of its parts and it's
a lot of fun like we keep adding new
like Bingo spaces all the time people
get real competitive with how we play
Bingo like I never I haven't played
bingo in like I don't know 15 years and
all of a sudden like we're doing it
three times a week it's no it's fun it's
goofy fun every stream turns into a
party too like the whole origin of all
those videos they come from twitch
streams and it's just a it's just Good
Times Good Vibes and we all just kind of
laugh at like because what else can you
do right because the whole situation is
so ridiculous in fact our last stream on
Monday night we had someone
um the someone who created Tick Tock
that sniperwolf stole in that video in
fact we were reacting to sniper's
reaction to that video
to that Tick Tock where the uh Mikey
skates is The Tick Tock account he came
in and said hey um yeah I'm the guy that
made that Tick Tock and I asked her uh
in the comments like you didn't have my
permission to do that and I can't find
my comment in uh her video because and
we found out we did a little digging she
filters that she and her team they
filter out keywords like I think it's
permission
content
you know really those okay those gross
four-letter words
so if someone were to sue her for
copyright infringement the fact that
she's filtering out permission proves
proves willful infringement and that's
the thing that when you if you can
really prove you can really them it
doubles the penalties
so it's it's just weird man it's just I
mean
one of the things I don't know what to
say I mean you know that's the only way
that that this changes
but at this end of the day I don't know
if that's the best thing for the
community is to get it like a an anti
a verdict that says this is not fair use
right right and that's the whole thing
it's like what is this all snowballing
towards what will this lead to I
genuinely don't know
um I I hope it's I mean like will
YouTube ever do anything probably not no
but it's just like at least I'm just
doing my part
kind of like tell people about like well
this is what's happening and here's why
it's not okay maybe we alert the the
creators of all these tick tocks that
Sniper Wolf uh steals we tell them like
this is how you can report it oh because
there's a way to do it right you know um
there's a way to flag it a very specific
way and then you have to like call out
the the time stamps where she uses it
and and link your original video to it
but it's not impossible and you know if
that snowballs if we turn that into a
movement that might be the way to do it
but you know I'm still working on that
that's that's something that would take
a few weeks or months to really
coordinate but anyways I do feel like
this is headed towards some end it would
be interesting if you had an attorney
that
was available
on a reasonable basis to work on
something like this too if they wanted
to pursue that because even just sending
like a legal letter if she has good
um counsel
and she should because she's very
wealthy they will tell her you have you
will 100 lose this you need to settle
this
so if you just send her a legal letter
there's a good shot that they're just
going to settle with you
yeah I don't it's interesting I don't
know what path uh the right path is to
take here time uh sent a message caught
my daughter watching sniperwolf one year
ago I schooled her on content thieves
now she's obsessed with watching Jacks
shut up
mom
it's really cool
it's like you walked they're like
turn that off
had my door closed don't you knock
so right oh that's awesome that see that
just makes my heart grow three sizes
hearing like that I also want to
say that I think it's great that you go
back and tag all the creators of content
she uses too it's the very least I could
do we try to hunt them down I mean like
some are easier to find than others but
like it's it's just one of those like
you gotta credit the creators because
that's where all this shit's coming from
you can't Sniper Wolf wouldn't have a
goddamn Channel if it weren't for the
creators so it's just one of those like
small things that we try to do and also
try to like reinstate like hey this is
important check out these guys you know
these people that make these videos if
you want to see more and this should
kind of be the norm part of the norm but
I'm so boxing I think the reason she
doesn't tag them is because she it's
better for her if they don't know
100 no that's a really good theory yeah
right because the people like that's
I've had multiple people come to these
streams and be like hey I you know I had
no idea if she 100 times them when we
reached out like in the first main video
I made when we reached out to a bunch of
creators and way more creators than we
show in the video every single one of
them had no idea they had no idea that
sniperwolf was reacting to their content
and some of them were genuinely upset
about that like
um one guy was like well I'm gonna
pursue a legal action against that
um I have no idea what happened to that
but like
that's just proof she doesn't get
permission doesn't ask permission just
Steals and there's like about a month in
between when like the uh the original
videos are posted and when sniperwolf
reacts to it there's a good month or so
I think she reloads the content that far
ahead of time
uh
so that's a question because like then
you have to ask like how does she find
the content and I've had a few like
theories because like most of the
content she reacts to is already viral
and has been viral but every once in a
while I'll find an original Tick Tock
she reacted to that only has like a
thousand views or so but and I'm like
how does she even find it and it's if
the video that sniperwolf uploads is
called try not to say wow challenge
impossible then The Tick Tock itself
will actually have in the caption try
not to say wow challenge impossible and
it's one of those like oh my God she
just like searched that and grabbed
whatever she could find I think she's
gotta have
several people a full-time looking
absolutely looking for just sending her
links absolutely no it's got to be a
well-coordinated
um you know machine a well-oiled machine
it's not just our campy so uh do you
have plans for this channel if the
Sniper Wolf thing let's say it gets
resolved somehow are you gonna continue
on this channel do you have uh plans
into the future you've grown such a nice
Community there be ashamed to leave it
it's a really cool Community like
everyone it's just this it just feels
good like everyone's behind this cause
and it's really cool so no to answer
your question I don't know there's a
possibility we investigate um another
um streamer who violates a lot of the
same you know laws and and it's kind of
doing the same thing and we kind of go
down that route that road possibly
um but I don't know and it's an
interesting question like what would
happen Beyond this
um because right now the whole like
people are loving the the bingo streams
we got going on and it's it's it's just
a I don't know it's a positive it's
really good time it's a good experience
but I do have to like I talk with my my
own counsel I have like my own small
team of writers and editors that I
confer with and you know we've often
talked about like what comes after this
and I don't have an answer for that but
something we'll figure it out I'm not
too worried about that there you go
there it is guys films
[Applause]
to definitely go enjoy his new channel
which everybody is saying is the funnest
place on the internet everyone's saying
Bingo it's true everyone's here Dan's
girlfriend is a big fan she is she she
watches every episode that's awesome I
didn't know that oh well she saw you on
the show when we were talking about it
right yeah yeah she went there and she
went and checked it out and uh yeah she
works from home and uh she's an artist
and so while she's drawing she's always
watching YouTube videos and you know uh
the juju jacks films has entered the
regular rotation now so there you go
there it is I love it man I love to see
that people are watching it's so cool I
mean it's so cool it's wild man oh so
can I recommend Ben collect you could be
a good one too oh I know all about Ben
Stiller yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm inside your walls bin oh I forgot
about that whole meme I know it's about
him yeah yeah yeah oh man because he got
he's been
uh accused or alleged some some shady
you know right recently yeah yeah
some allegations against him he he
invited um
besides stealing and only fans girl
to come to a video with him a podcast a
podcast and it was like it's like his
second episode he's already sexually
harassing and he goes Christ he goes hey
do you want to make an only fans video
together
she's like what he's like yeah since
you're helping me out on my podcast I
thought I'd help you out on your I like
fans and then she goes no thanks
and then he goes okay never mind I found
someone else for the podcast
wow what a charmer wow that's totally
done that I think to to another girl
yeah I think a second person came out
and said yes his ammo experience it's
awesome yeah what a just what a what a
well-adjusted man I love how I just love
how it's like hey do you want to come
have sex with me no okay well anyway I
canceling the podcast just immediately
afterwards like so making sure and sell
Vibes respect respect the uh the the
honesty and that I guess sure if there's
something to respect silver lighting
there's an honest you can't call him a
dishonest man
well not in that case
yeah let's not pushing on Ben telek all
right we're gonna put the link in the
description everybody enjoy it's a
beautiful cause it's a great content
it's Jack's films one of the greatest
that ever did it on YouTube
thank you kindly and I may I just
reinstate just my love for for you Ethan
for everyone uh behind the uh the H3
podcast it's it's been far too long
buddy thanks so much for having me on
great to see you likewise
keep going man keep going we love it we
support you
well that's uh Jack's films everybody
Jack's films
films
um now
something uh really interesting came to
light here
Dan is start start there I was like Dan
it's getting a little uncomfortable I
was trying to hang up I'm doing the
controlling multiple computers thing
today and it's getting a little but
something that we need to focus in on
that came to light
they did not invite Jax
now I think we need that in solidarity
not go
was he nominated
I don't know he wasn't invited
so probably not
what are you saying about Jax he's I'm
not saying anything about him but always
be there his invite should be Evergreen
it should be it's like Jack Nicholson
he's like Jack Nicholson at the Oscars
yeah he's like just always there yeah
interesting
all right I'm I'm
as I'm talking to you I'm restoring the
council here I have to take a look at
that I just want to see it I'm gonna go
I'm going to look at Love's uh
cute yeah what is it called
you got my you should try it you just
want to look at it I see oh that's
like a great I'm trying to show the
camera oh uh here so wait is that Curry
because it looks like gravy it's kind of
like gravy it's the same thing as gravy
but it's like it's Japanese right does
it have Japanese
that sounds good boy that chicken looks
nice in the middle and they didn't put
the Curry on on top they put it in next
to it so I poured it doesn't get soggy
yeah very smart shout out to Champions
Curry shout out
by the way I noticed I notice in chat uh
crate there was a group of Kratom
enthusiasts who were very offended
wait what really yeah I guess there's a
lot of people that use it for medicinal
purpose and they swear it does good for
them so
I guess I you know what I I just frankly
don't know that much about kratom
I know the thing I know about creative
is like super unregulated nobody knows
where it's coming from
there's like asbestosides in it and
uh illegal in a few States oh is it
illegal now okay
not everywhere but but go for it if it
helps you I mean you know how I feel
about drugs I'm Pro drugs
responsible usage of drugs that is
all right nice to connect with uh Jack
I'm glad he's doing well that that's
very that's great yeah
he has the full support of the H3 family
Nation
which I'll be saying to the streamies
after Sunday night when we win best
podcast
yes sir and they have to announce it
during the break because we're not there
if they okay so yeah there's a there's a
few different Forks if we go
and they announce and we win but they
announced it during a break I'll still
be happy but it's pretty funny right but
then if we went if we go there and we
don't win and it was announced during a
break
friendship is over right
hey guys I'm so sorry to interrupt we
gotta go to break friendship with
Streamys is over
I mean I get it if they don't want it to
be a main thing though it never has been
whatever
whatever let's just well let's just
cross our fingers that one of you guys
gets covered
stop
just kidding no worries listen I don't
affect if you guys have covet okay it's
just a joke
you know
but here here's the reason why this all
really did happen
uh it's all Hassan's fault and I have
proof
and uh Zach close your eyes or look away
if you need to
but here is he here he is wearing
Credence clean water revival uh
Revel
clydence kleinwater Revival
tough man it all went downhill from here
I saw your show that a fan brought a
record for you did that did that
with you could that have been it I did a
half signature so it wasn't a full
signature so did does that bypass the
curse yeah as long as my full being is
not on there we're good man smart smart
yeah my OCD is always thinking Brother
Big Brain you've got out of that one
yeah I saw that though and I understand
that they're trying to be funny
but I would tell people not to do that
would you say the same yeah I I mean it
was all in good fun if you will I know
that yeah it wasn't good it was in good
fun it wasn't mean-spirited I would
assume but you really do get debilitated
by that
yeah it's a real thing
yeah
glidden's clean water yep
no it helps that you still don't know
the name of the band and I never will
thank God thank you you never actually
uh you know touch on the actual curse
here on the show well what are you
talking about is the curse of clydens
Klein Water Club kleinville
that's it there you go
uh
quartering friend of the show cereal
and pier in his basement yeah
what's Jeremy up to let's see ordering
is a low IQ inbred
this is real interesting he was meant to
have a debate
which I don't think he would be very
good at just oh God no he wanted to
debate Hassan I would like to discuss
why you hate white people so much that
is a losing um platform my
friend
debate format charity of your choosing
then the serfs and other political uh
YouTuber said the courting challenged me
to a debate and stipulated it would
require a ten thousand dollar charity
donation when I raised the money he said
people in the Stream were saying mean
things about him pissing in his basement
and he backed out as soon as we reached
the goal that's understandable though
if they were mean maybe I'll yeah they
were my trash can right that's like too
far on the internet yeah they were mean
to him that's too far don't be mean on
the internet guys maybe he thought it
was a masturbate maybe it was a type you
jerked off into the
basement into the basement drain yeah
yeah that frankly wouldn't
I'd be more surprised if he wasn't doing
that
you know it all goes down the basement
dream brother
doesn't matter what it is
so there it is the quartering uh backed
out of a date a debate because he pees
in his basement very good well so he was
backing out of that that account was
referring to a previous incident
we don't know if the Hassan or anything
is still on I mean I haven't talked to
him about it but assuming he didn't
respond to him I really doubt that this
is happening
you know what's the point could the
quartering like what literally is the
point I wouldn't debate the quartering
just because
that would be such a juicer don't
are you serious yeah I don't
even know what to talk because it's like
okay yeah you're dumb he's like yeah I'm
a big dumb oaf like who cares right like
he does nothing he says matters
to him or his fans yeah
[Music]
foreign
the man has a barn dedicated to his
obsession
with free is here to stay Reese Bree Lee
Larson it's just the he does not care
the man has a channel where he's he's
encouraging kids to send them his
contact info so he can mail them toys
and candies see don't think you could
find another channel that Praises Brie
Larson as much as me
that may be true debris shed so that
that's where I'm coming from
but uh and if Dan wants it maybe I
should do it well he didn't challenge
you to a debate we're purely speculating
here but you were just saying I don't
think I would but it's like I mean talk
to
Pearl
I mean Jeremy has a bigger audience than
her the thing about pearls like she had
this very specific thesis
that she'd never been properly
challenged on The Oaf is like he's just
like well he had one he's just like a
girl
what was Jeremy's thesis to Hassan that
he hates white people
I said well okay but that's a that's a
debate for Hassan he actually want that
would be a easy debate for Hassan I
think you know
but again it's not a good faith premise
it's stupid yeah
yeah he's like the human embodiment of a
fart cloud it just it's everywhere
you can't pin him down just stinks and
then you end up smelling like farts yeah
yeah ephemeral ephemeral thank you
Topgolf Goofs I love Top Golf goofs
Top Golf goofs what is this what the
according to a piece of dude hey
NASCAR
under the knee dude that's not even like
okay the racist aside it's not even
funny at all
and then including the racist it's
psychotic
and that's the point that's my point
about him
like what can you say to this man
thanks
yeah
shout out to the man who sits in his
basement
uh Topgolf goofs
take a look
oh God oh God I saw this it's so good
dude hold on wait why is it opening life
happened okay yeah
I've never seen what Max
[Music]
oh my God the response of his friends
he just walks away like he hit the ball
oh got it dude Topgolf is scary I
don't see how this place is possible
drunk Hooligans sling swinging clubs
somebody's gonna die there
I'm surely there are people who died
there we looked it up we couldn't find
anyone well they have the the suicide
Nets to catch drunks that fall off the
front so but I'm I'm worried about
people next door being hit by clubs or
golf balls either flying out of the hand
you know you can hit a golf ball real
weird it can go 90 degrees right that's
true I mean
we've been bowling for uh for a century
right that's pretty dangerous too just
you're slinging like heavy ass balls
around I mean people get hit by bowling
balls I'm not saying golf as a sport is
dangerous I'm saying Top Golf specific
psycho I got but and I love it
there by the way I think there's just a
reasonable expectation when you go to
you know a bowling alley or a top golf
that you might get whacked in the head
you know what's funny they make you sign
a release to play this really I've never
done that dude they make you the person
who organizes the event has to sign a
release before they give you the aisle
okay I guess I've never organized it so
but when I first went they made me send
it to my friend I had to sign it and my
friend had to sign it really they let
you off the hook
hmm so I could have gone Buck Wild and
you should have jumped you should have
jumped no paper trail
I never seen anything like this though
so shout out to Max wherever you are
well done sir
you scared your friends man
[Laughter]
oh Max Max are you okay
relax
[Music]
oh dude that's awesome
yo where'd everyone go it's just Olivia
everybody's out
boring everybody's gone boring
I'm here okay you feeling bad maybe
starting to feel it all right a little
bit surprisingly my stomach hurts a lot
I don't know what that's about could be
I mean it probably is yeah and then is
Lena feeling anything or no
she said she feels fine
that's good so you'll have someone to
take care of you hopefully she doesn't
get sick too yeah
it's weird she took three tests and two
of them are negative
and one was positive but she's got it
yeah
um breaking news courtesy of uh Mega
awesome nerd
uh oh boy big news big news oh boy
big news send to you sent it to you okay
here we go big breaking news everybody I
knew it
huh
Essex did this happen in England yeah
they're top offers in England no wonder
people are dying there they don't know
what they're doing
Ethan golf is from the UK
what is it they did they invented golf
the act of hitting is from England of
course I believe uh it's uh Scotland
right
that makes sense they have beautiful
green grass
yeah they don't need to like dump all
the drinkable water yeah and to be clear
we love the Scots here I didn't say
anything about the Scots I
on the on the English yeah the English
who we do also love absolutely the Sun
never sets on my love for all the
English and the British warmer former
colleagues yeah Essex crime clay uh
clacton man died from spine injury after
falling from height at golf Topgolf oh
my God
oh a man was arrested wait so he was he
murdered
wait I said A man was arrested in
connection with the incident
okay that kind of changes the
an Essex man who fell from height at a
golf driving range has died police
investigation has been launched into the
death of him a 22 year old man following
an incident
Mr uh Mr groom is understood to have
been attending a work Christmas party
at the work Christmas party man and the
end of the year resentments
interpersonal resentments talk about a
buzz kill
you're stare having a drink
getting ready for Christmas and then
these brothers of course Connor has to
fall off and die typical
typical O'Connor well it sounds like
there was Foul Play potentially Mr groom
was rushed to the Royal London Hospital
he died rest in peace
during the hearing
uh Marianne Robson said on December the
22 year old gentleman was at golf
driving range an incident occurred and
he was discovered on the ground
unresponsive that sounds like Foul Play
well tell me what happened despite
treatment he passed away a postmortem
took place
to determine the cause
the cause was served it's not like the
beginning of a of a madcap mystery story
you know what I mean this is like a
modern-day Sherlock yeah we need a
Sherlock for this one don't bother wait
I have to know what happened
okay so a man was arrested inquiries
remain ongoing a spokesman for the
police force said we are investigating
following reports from an incident in
which man fell from height
yada yada 22 year old man was taken we
know that yep he died we know 22 year
old man from kolkter was arrested on
January 4th on suspicion
of
g b h without intent was it an accident
he has since been released my friend
Neil bent over this happened sounds like
an accidental
sounds like an accident oh he was here
what are you doing here
hello oh you're back hey
welcome back
uh Grievous uh bodily harm is the uh
gbeh what is that what does that charge
mean in England is it like manslaughter
uh is English criminal law to use
describes severest forms of battery
oh so it sounds like they got in a fight
after he fell no no like they were
probably fighting and they got in a
tussle and one of them fell off so he
didn't mean to like murder him but he
was
in a fight with him gbh without intent
rest in peace man as long as it was in
Chapel I'm good man yeah we need to
protect Chapel like the queen herself
who we did not protect when she's in a
box now so Chapel I hope you're better
protected than the queen was who's in
the Box
uh people cannot stop complimenting me
on my weight loss
keemstar of all people
came out uh and now he's an H3 fan since
I'm not fat anymore well he can finally
come out as an H3 fan right he's always
been an agent uh keemstar
complimenting it's misspelled I think
keemstar wrote this keemstar definitely
posted this
laughs
right like that's how keemstar would
spell that
all right let's see big shout out to Mr
Beast look look y'all know I can hate
Ethan Klein right but look at him losing
weight right now it's it's inspiring to
see thank you brother a bunch of
influencers getting in shape losing
weight oh you didn't even show a picture
to everyone to be an infant shut up I
don't need your congrats no that's all
congratulations
[Applause]
he wants you to like him so bad it's not
happening
he sent me some uh personalized messages
um yeah congrats to Ethan Klein wow big
shout out to Ethan Klein that sounds
good it's good so okay he's really
coming around
it doesn't matter as you can bring me
all the beef jerky cheese and syrup in
the world and I will not like you
that that are uh that that four-wheeler
has has wrote off it's got stuck in the
ditch
that ride is gone
um Ethan oh God that sounds so real
don't play that one
that one's scary
uh Birds aren't real guy friend of the
show
he was on a while ago he went on Fox
news of all places and just confused the
hell out of him yeah and
you know it really just goes to show
just how dumb these people are I mean
take a look at this
MV but we can control every bird in the
sky we can I mean and I appreciate you
allowing me to share this information on
here a lot of the media won't let me
talk about is this a shtick
I mean do you really I mean are do you
really in your heart why would it be a
stick
because I mean you you were everywhere
you report on UFOs in the show yes well
I don't report on that UFOs are I mean I
respect what you guys talk about on here
you're letting bird robots on the show
you're letting UFOs so do you think I
could see the government using some
birds maybe as drones I love that
they're like uh oh my God the conspiracy
theorist in me I like the theory that
some birds are drones
but all birds come on
that's just too many birds pigeons here
in New York City every every bird every
bird in every pigeon here in New York
City he's so good how did he get on
control everybody he's actually he's
playing it so well yeah he's so good at
this by now he is this man I don't think
a joke's ever been run this far for this
long a joke well people are how are
people still stick like this
stick joke I don't know what you're
talking about right right right
but then
I'm just I'm baffled how I mean this is
Jesse Waters who now that uh Tucker
Carlson has gone I believe that this is
this guy who's this no there's a
substitute he's got a teacher so this is
oh this is Prime look it's Jesse Watters
Prime Time yo this is the prime time
slot yeah so this isn't even like just
like filler on the daytime programming
this is like this is like their lead
story for the night at least soy tonight
are all birds fake
oh
it's awesome there it is guys Fox News
this is what your grandparents are
watching yeah and some of your parents
unfortunately
if they come and ask you about the robot
Birds you know what happened and some of
uh Donna's Mod game right true
listen guys just remember
he takes it a little far but in my
opinion there's gotta be at least a few
bird drones
surveillance drones there has to be yeah
yeah logic he just takes it too far but
I'm with him
well my impending doom of of birds I
mean I feel is valid now because they uh
you know are just a bunch of flying
robots so is the thought of birds being
robots more or less scary to you I think
less scary right less yeah really that's
nice I gotta be honest I'm offended by
all this bird slander they're all real
nothing
the real is they look at that real as
how do you improved why don't you drop
one of those birds and so it can fly
away I can't see the camera okay he was
holding up all of his little birds ready
to step on one of them
pretty bird
remember that Petey oh yeah
All Right Moving On Moving On
motorcycle guy he says the n-word with
an a at the end a white guy can we show
that
uh YouTube probably Skip it's pretty
funny the clip is it worth not because
of the slur but because the man makes a
total fool of the rest of it I guess I
can I'll just put it on mute the N word
so it goes like hey what's up n-word I
guess he's just trying to flex
with
dude he went there to flex drop the end
bomb and then this happened
how good is that and then he
can't even run away
you know
usually you know what the N word is I
would assume when you drop a slur like
that you want to get away real quick
idiot
wait how much did he drop dude it's
like a pinata
falling out wait hold on let's
count all the he dropped
all right so you should run mute it
after he says it okay he said it right
there I think
so let's see
[Music]
what's up first he loses his phone okay
now he's losing let's see he lost his
glasses in his hat
okay
then
there's something else Phil I don't I
don't know what that is
and he lost himself
it was so funny what a dumbass bro you
probably can't even picked that thing up
you can see I don't think this guy knows
what he's doing look at his hands when
he drops in
his hand on the gas just totally Goofs
off the thing
like if you try to watch his hand with
his right hand
I don't know
you're a motorcycle driver yeah so you
to gas you do that right yeah so it's a
classic thing if you kind of have to
hold on you grip harder and you throttle
harder you gotta let go it's a typical
beginner mistake I I think wasn't he I
think he was trying to rev and then he
kind of hit that slope and then here's
these revving and hitting the break but
when he hit that rev he let go of the
break and then it kept going so again he
was trying to flex and it made it worse
I think he was
definitely meant to drop in though yeah
yeah I know he was trying to trying to
do something one more time just for
posterity here he drops the end bomb
let's let's unmute it
so sick he's so dope this guy's the
coolest
whole song
just let go bro
he's holding on onto like he's gonna
save it you just let go let go and you
stop yeah dude that's you that's so
embarrassing you just I think at that
point you leave the motorcycle and go
home yeah you can't stick around in an
environment in front of a bunch of kids
too it's extra funny just leave leave
all your stuff
just go home bro our diagnosis is
delusional so I came home on Wednesday
that girl knows she knows I think the
mystery flying off at the end was
just the motorcycle braking too I just
noticed that yeah yeah right
well we love him don't we
also just a little quick uh happy news
he's not a friend of the show uh I've
never talked to him but
a lot of you guys know him not an enemy
either not an enemy we haven't we we
haven't established formal diplomatic
ties no correct yeah but Hank Green who
uh so uh
he was diagnosed with cancer of a little
while ago and he's in remission so
that's good news
based on a lot of research a lot of
evidence a lot of hard work a lot of the
people going through similar things yeah
uh Hodgkin's lymphomas chemotherapy and
then radiation which I finished uh all
that about a week ago and I had my first
post treatment followed with my
oncologist today
as of today
I am officially
in complete remission
which means and I I don't have cancer
anymore
uh I I we have another scan in three
months to follow up and then we keep a
really close eye on it is it still uh
not in substantial risk of relapse but
it's pretty low
um but hey if it happens we'll take that
on too
but
May everyone who uh faces cancer down
have such a outcome I hope only the best
cancer and uh well done to uh or
not well done I don't think necessarily
that's the right but but congratulations
yeah
not to him yeah let's not even try to uh
so it's all good news and then more good
news fresh and fit have been permanently
banned now I know we've click baited
this but I'm here to say that this time
they have been
permanently
removed from YouTube Partner program
they are done uh what was that uh and I
couldn't and I mean first the first
amendment is crying I'm so sad no this
is super up this is actually kind
of the end it's kind of the end of the
United States of America
Civil War in the words of Temple Civil
War yes but before we uh jump into that
I just need to uh use the restroom real
quick so I'll be right back all righty
leave me hanging there
hi Dan it's just you down on the council
we're chilling oh maybe what's that you
wearing a robe yeah you just coughed in
Olivia's face bro oh I forgot
it's a mirror that meant to go
the are you doing
it is a robe
let's see it showed off
damn green screen okay yeah it's not the
invisible robe very cool
yeah it's invisibility cloak I got it
from Harry Potter world that's very cool
why it's so weird I'm wearing a hat
why is that weird dude
uh how often do you wear hats sir I mean
I'll wear a kangal every now and again
but like
that's date Zach though yeah you're
right yeah but what's wrong with the hat
I like this hat I didn't say there's
anything wrong with it I just I was
taken off guard I think I think it's
kind of weird that you come in with a
hat yeah clearly Ian's thing you don't
wear uh like is it a rolly hat it's from
the Concord de Elegance what is it yes
Pebble Beach so it's a Rolex official
hat thank you very much well there you
go
it makes sense
you know when I came in with a bottom-up
shirt
like one week ago Zach came up to me and
he forced me to take it off no what what
happened bro
you I'm not gonna stay on air what you
told me but okay no
just saying bro what you told me wasn't
nice
what does that mean they call you the
casler or something yeah oh my God love
Yeah apologize right now well I was
really really mad okay okay
that's your on your honor I was really
really mad no I didn't say that I
wouldn't
ever so we're out we're having fun here
yeah we're having fun we're having fun
here people
um yeah Zach no you don't you don't wear
hats and like you said when you do it's
usually like a kangal when you're when
you're really feeling yourself or you're
like in your Lou you're you're in your
Lou bag that day or something
um so yeah you're just strolling him
with a Rolex uh baseball cap all of a
sudden
it was it stood out to
to frankly to all of us I mean we all
noticed it immediately right you know
usually I don't like wearing hats
because I get headaches from them if I'm
being completely honest
um and you know I have that big noggin
of yours but luscious locks which you
know
um
but I I want to wear a hat today I might
wear it again I might wear it a time
after that and I don't want to feel
shame for it what's that shame but like
we just Ian just noted it earlier and
you kind of recoiled at that
I think I think it's a fair observation
is all I'm trying to say that's all I'm
trying to say we're gonna leave it at
that we can leave it at that you called
yourself Golf Course Greg when I walked
in yeah I have my golf attire she said
that he's golfing today you have a new
person
mentally I'm golf Lou
are we are we kind of soft launching a
new character today
what was it Golf Course Craig Golf
Course Craig I thought is what he said
and I was like who the is this guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
um Jacinda just donated 20 smackaroons
to the H3 podcast and said nothing helps
me prepare for a night shift in the ER
like starting the day with the podcast
also Olivia is Queen love y'all oh my
God you are queen you are the night
shift you night shifters Night Nurse
that's incredible wait isn't that kind
of
wait a minute it's not a it's a it's a
baby nurse
okay that's amazing
it's like hardcore nurse but hardcore
gotcha
he went to the bathroom he's clogging up
the toilet grumpy oh he's taking a
dumper any dude maybe are you sitting in
my seat right now rolling around trying
to get covered
doing anything he can to get out of the
Streamys I really hope I didn't ruin for
you guys I hope you guys stop saying you
like dude it like there is a highly
contagious virus that has been going
around for years uh is not
it's not on you for uh catching it
thank you Dan could you say it's not
your fault it's not your fault
thank you it's not your fault
definitely um
to clarify you know if there's
whatever the rules say whatever it is we
will abide by that you know we're not
gonna go and put people at risk yeah
that's the last thing I think anybody on
This Crew would want to do uh regardless
of the framing from certain individuals
foreign
not sure who I'm referring to but I just
want to do the right thing yeah and so
do we so you know just clarifying that
we won't go if it's a risk who couldn't
decide that okay well that was one of
these conversation's over trying to push
back on no I'm kidding here's the thing
that I'll emphasize
we looked at the CDC guidelines we're
following that and we're notifying the
streamies we've literally done it this
in the most good faith way possible
there's nothing more we can do
yep right I don't know if this matters
but xqc is supposed to be presenting so
if you do win
we don't know that he's presenting the
podcast category though so that would be
awesome okay
that would be pretty interesting
but it would also be devastating if we
lost and he gave the award to someone
else that would be less fun
are they gonna have like a sign language
interpreter for xqc
[Music]
oh
maybe you should always walk the sign
language interpreter needs an
interpreter themselves though
room of interpreters
sorry guys God damn it I can eat for one
second y'all kill me do you slam another
donut it's the same one oh
there was a bit left and I finished I
finished the job wait are people
actually angry that
no just
about what about just damn it like
before
damage control yeah
listen we were having a live we just
found out all of this right before we
went live and we're literally talking
through it live on the show but I mean I
guess if you heard the first like
minute of the conversation and then
immediately rushed uh to the subreddit
to go complain you might have missed the
part where we did kind of come to the
conclusion that yeah this probably isn't
happening so what
what
the Streamys yeah it's probably not
happening since when
that's what what do you mean since about
you I thought we decided we're going if
nobody goes but gets positive yeah
that's what we decided
the poll was like 83 percent
no I don't care about the pole
no offense to our audience wait you're
letting me off the hook I thought I was
I thought I was gonna have to do this no
the CDC thing yeah the CDC rules said if
as long as you wear a mask when you're
in right right around people yeah yeah
I'm just going on the assumption that
more of us will or
fairly likely to say if people start
getting sick then we're not going to go
yeah which is why I told I wanted to
notify the Streamys to be fair to them
that there's a chance we might not come
or there's a chance they don't want us
to risk us going there to get anyone
sick
yep it doesn't get more fair than that
my friends do not come do not come
streaming says
I'm gonna come what more could I what
more could we do hold on I'm coming hold
on all right so let's talk about fresh
and fresh and fizzled out yeah
coconuts and demonetized
um
all right out of here
this keyboard's so weird I'm just
sending a note
all right so here is
uh
uh the Knuckleheads themselves crying
that they've lost everything
and I'm just so tragically sad for them
I mean how how much worse can my week
get no streamies and now fresh from 50
monetizers
yeah what a bummer here it is as you
guys oh yeah play the sad music that'll
that's that's fitting
oh I had a show scheduled earlier with
psych hacks but we had to uh cancel
because we got some really you know
sucky news
um crazy news yeah crazy news real talk
yeah and and you know we did we made
moves on the side knowing that this
could potentially happen
and guys we the channel has been kicked
off the YouTube Partner program just
keep it straight look right now you
can't even super chat or no dude first I
know the Statue of Liberty's crying
right now don't you get it
don't you understand what's at stake
thank you
it's all at stake if fresh and fit can't
come on to YouTube and make money by
being misogynistic freaks then where are
we
what's next Isis oh right that was that
did happen before
you can't remember chat right now yep
so this is the beginning of the end of
this era so we are throwing chat so yeah
so we've worked really hard to bring
people on that have different viewpoints
right not really
well no they do like
some people think
you know the Holocaust didn't happen and
others think that the numbers were just
greatly exaggerated there's different
points of view well right and some so
what some of their guests were like no
it's okay to beat your wife up and some
are like I I probably wouldn't say that
publicly but I agree right different
opinions right different perspective and
perspectives garyvee
okay maybe I was I was judging them
harshly yeah from perspectives yeah
right some of them very controversial
some of them that may or may not be
um
politically correct
and that's unfortunately the risk that
you take when you make the kind of
content that we do even other people
okay so they're aware of kind of the
that that's nice they're being aware of
it yeah that would that was
they're taking a huge beating on the
stock market yeah I mean despite having
one of the best years by the way thank
you to uh fresh for alerting me to that
I I didn't realize Rumble is on the
stock it's on the stock market their
financials are public and they uh are
hammering money well of course they are
I mean that makes sense but I didn't
know that information was publicly
available so that is is Rumble a
publicly traded company
I mean it's a big business at this point
well they're up 2.5 percent today
they heard fresh and fit is coming do uh
just look at uh all time on them okay
let's go Max
I mean oh that's an interesting graph
I mean I've seen worse
yeah
uh it's not like they're going out of
business tomorrow but I I didn't realize
that their financials were so shaky
I was reading up a little bit about it
last night
um and their user growth has uh
stagnated apparently I mean it took
YouTube like three decades before it was
even profitable I don't know how Rumble
expects to come in and make money well
that and that's the thing about all of
these platforms and like Kik for example
why none of that has ever made sense
and in any regard other than the
gambling advertising up front before
yeah like it it their business model
makes zero sense unless you
consider that they're making billions
off of the stakes but everybody knows
that
they deny it right they're doing it for
free speech yeah that's why that's why
my good friend train wreck and xqc and
Aiden Ross all the top gambling
streamers have come over to kick
That's so exciting and random
here it is
somebody says he got a hair thing his
hair does look more you know I I was
thinking that as well he's like bro you
still got to pay off this hair you're
right maybe he didn't even talk about it
openly like yeah he talked about it with
snico right okay what did he do he got a
hair transplant they removed uh back a
piece of his hair in the back and then
put it forward it healed real fast
yeah good for him looks pretty good yeah
I mean
it looks like a hair transplant I will
say that like it was very but I I think
that's because we have made
tab we've noticed his hairline a lot in
the past right so well it's giving like
you know how DJ Khaled like uses paint
or like spray paint to make his to line
himself up giving that a little but I
think good for him in that sense it
looked just like a cappuccino although
how much is a hair transplant like I
said this this could not come at a worse
time for him
yeah God damn reviews and everything I
know a lot of you guys send me messages
and trust me I'll look at them I really
do look at them and as a matter of fact
I saved them too because I sent some of
them to Fresh today yeah when you guys
send me your DMs and say yo you saved my
life yo you sent me a picture of your
credit score yo my girl is making
sandwiches now or whatever it is right
you know what's crazy that he actually
said that and I don't think he was
really kidding no of course not he
wasn't he he was smiled but he wasn't
kidding no yo thank you guys my girls
making me sandwiches now the
Jesus that's that's really it
it's really incredible my man yeah
um that really means a lot to us right
yeah helped a lot of you guys
um
from killing yourselves from
injuring yourself from making a really
bad decision or doing something that
that you can't
um necessarily take back
what I'm asking you guys is just like
we've saved you guys we need you guys to
save us
we need you guys to support us on Rumble
because that's the last Bastion of free
speech at this point it's it yeah Rumble
baby and kick
which I'm going to talk about next the
fousey stuff
uh it's the last Sebastian a free speech
uh they really he's right they don't
give a what's on their platform
great yep
Free Speech baby
and it's always and somehow Free Speech
always ends up with uh pedophiles and
Nazis yeah so weird
we need a place where pedophiles and
Nazis can meet together and talk about
being them true selves
.com like you need to go on there right
now
follow the channel subscribe it's five
bucks a month and when I stand on this
one I truly say we have saved more lives
and saved more men's impacted more men's
lives than any other podcast on any
platform and it shows concretely say
that thanks to you guys finished so
coconut and Barbados you didn't do
bro
foreign
they really building themselves up you
know
favors and it shows
concretely say that thanks to you guys
finished so is that so you need to open
up the pressure fit Rumble okay right
now and then go to subscribers yeah yeah
so the chats be open in the live chat as
well
you know what I mean I'm just gonna say
it
guys we're getting attacked on at all
angles I've been like
what was that him or you Zack what
did he hit the record scratch
that was me okay I was like because he
would do that yeah no it seemed approach
I love it Bangles I've been like
whether it's the Press writing articles
on us
videos getting taken down that other
channels are not getting taken down and
it's the same exact content or whatever
it may be Rubble getting hit right for
free speech uh but we're getting hit for
free speech yeah okay that's an
interesting way to spin it
all I said was free speech
okay fine I said that um Holocaust
didn't happen
and that Protocols of Zion is a good one
[Music]
Free Speech stuff
I may have said in a free speech kind of
way
that it's okay to hit your uh hit your
wife if she doesn't make you a sandwich
in a free speech kind of way in a free
speechy way
I wonder how many abusive relationships
they've started right yeah like how do
you that sandwich comments so how do you
get your significant other to make you a
sandwich
how do you get that to happen without
like
[Laughter]
[Music]
what happened all the time just the
old-timey music
the video stopped playing is our
internet out oh no that was weird we
just yeah I mean how do you get a uh
your significant other do that other
than by like violence and intimidation
yeah no I agree
sweetie can you start making me
sandwiches every day I guess that works
too if you ask like that
right but then she's like well what are
you doing for me you're gonna wash the
dishes yeah yeah that's a fair trade I
suppose yeah maybe something tells me
that's not how these conversation goes
probably not
the audio's got what is this video man
like okay Reddit player
the Press writing articles on us
videos getting taken down that other
channels are not getting taken down and
it's the same exact content or whatever
it may be wow we're getting hit right
for free speech uh video like just get
strikes whatever it may be
guys it's got to the point now where
even where we shoot the location doesn't
want us to stay here yeah
this was really funny this is
morons built their studio in a
residential apartment
yep and they're complaining that the
landlord doesn't want them working there
they don't want them like having
shitloads of people in there coming in
and out at all hours being super loud
morons build it in a commercial space
yeah I somehow never knew that that's
funny I think it's Myron's apartment
so that makes all of like the bringing
girls over and getting them drunk and
putting them on the show thing like a
thousand times worse because his bed is
right there yes
and also it's like yeah bringing in like
dozens of people to have screaming
matches in your apartment
building it's insane I'm surprised that
they didn't get kicked out soon for sure
it's illegal because I mean that's why
they Zone yes
he's like yo my landlord's a feminist
bro
he's asking us to move out I move our
our highly industrial commercial office
out
crazy I didn't want to have to
say that I really don't want that
they're they're trying nobody Rumble
down like I think at some point there
was free speech where it was like okay
you know what you see what you got to
say We'll crucify you but nowadays free
speech is kind of like it's a different
thing I mean yo that was super deep of
coconuts yeah
hold on I gotta go back because I don't
know if I I was the most we've really
ever heard him like
it was a like a whole sentence he must
have planned that ahead of time yeah let
me listen to this because wow okay
but nowadays free speech is kind of like
is it even a thing I mean dude that's a
good question is it well he says before
the free speech is like whatever people
get mad at you they cancel you but now
crucify or crucify you
now but now now you can't even say
anything at all you literally can't
utter you can't open your mouth the
words don't exit yeah
on my live stream to uh probably like
twenty thousand lives in a residential
building yeah I can't say anything
dude coconuts is so interesting he goes
is it even a thing anymore yeah so
interesting anymore can you talk again
are you allowed to talk no not anymore
not really not really I shouldn't be
admitting this but interestingly I don't
know if I've made this joke
but his brain is a lot like a coconut
it's hard on the outside protective
shell but in the middle it's just a
fluid there's no there's no body it's
just fluid milk if you would he has milk
coconut milk for brains
saving children right oh that was
great we're saving you hold on hold on
hold on I'm sorry gotta see this
at some point there was free speech
where it was like okay you know what you
see what you got to say the sad music
classify you but nowadays free speech is
kind of like it's a different thing I
mean not really even a thing you should
be admitting this I don't know is it
saving children right right that was
great but saving you guys better
I guess he's talking about because he
used to work in human trafficking yeah
he was a Fed he worked for Homeland
Security so he goes listen
saving kids
from being human trafficked was good
yeah saving a bunch of crusty virgins
red pilling a bunch of people into
thinking that you should uh
smack your girlfriend if she has an
Instagram account
that's better than saving children
that's literally better than saving
children literally it's nothing could
top it
that's such a crazy thing to utter yeah
it's crazy thing to say actually play
more because it gets crazier
right after this what do you mean he's
so right
well in a sense he still is saving
children right
yeah kind of a nice twist there
thank you oh shot he's he's got to get
up because he's he's crying not because
of the kids but because of the
the men who can no longer watch him
argue with drunk teenage girls this is
Coconut's worst nightmare oh yeah he's
like hanging here right yeah what
do I do he's panicking let's see what he
has to say his coconut is turning right
now let's see what he spins
oh
yeah man this is tough bro
this is tough bro wait what happened did
they cut it yeah this is edited if you
want I I put the timestamp to this part
where he's crying in the dark side
directly to it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I need that
uh it's B direct link to the crying part
he just starts repeating stuff he's even
a thing by the way these guys fell off
kind of bad like the view okay the views
on their recent stuff has been pretty
unimpressive yeah
um that one got four hundred thousand
which that was like a big post for them
it was a big announcement but let's see
these ones I mean two weeks ago 36 000
yeah they fell off hard wait these are
videos go to the live tab
see what their streams are getting
uh this is the live tab apparent oh no
okay so
um oh God foosi wait what oh no they're
talking about I thought he's gonna be on
their show
but he was wasn't he at some point
Didn't I hear about that yeah he says
he's friends with Myra and now I guess
cool
uh here's one from one day ago 46 000.
man
saving lives well maybe they maybe they
went to rumble go back like a month
before before this whole incident well
and something else since they announced
that it's all over
it's over dude it's Joe ver
where is it hold on where is that it's
the one it's a red one no no yeah go
down
emergency meeting God what a weird
thumbnail yeah
what the hell
what the is this thumbnail it looks
like they're embracing
which I get it they've been through a
lot yeah so since they said it's ending
they've posted a video every day
some cases three one two well they're
probably they're doing their best to uh
shift Their audience off YouTube
but we know how that goes all right so
here we go was there something else you
want to see here
yeah uh coconuts right his flying solo
yeah yeah it's right after that not
really
and you know and I've already put just
skip forward a bit we're gonna uh
this is this part's good too you guys
just let it play you gotta just let it
play I want to watch the whole damn 26
minutes I mean I could watch the whole
thing we could
should we
I mean I'm down just play just play this
part you gotta see it yeah I have a time
stamp too it's all good a very important
part all right let me open it I'm just
opening the timestamp again is it a bad
thing I mean not really
and you know and I've already put
I've already put his concerned on my on
my uh money into this new studio for you
oh they cut out stuff
yeah the person who posted on our Reddit
did like a super cut they of this stream
but so this idiot invested all
of his money into a residential
Studio space this this has major Michael
Scott energy to me what this whole
section okay these guys have been that
successful podcasters for a while
did nobody tell you guys that you cannot
have a full-on studio
in a residential apartment
no
what happened to all the Slick
businessmen and red pellet Geniuses
nobody was like yo bro you should
probably move this those are the
people probably told him to do it though
soy
zoning laws are soy yeah you guys
I already already put it in you know
what I mean and it's a shame and it's
okay I'm never gonna that he's all in oh
oh oh wow I I I'm I'm doing this blah
blah blah and I hate doing this I love
doing this I'd be lying to you guys if I
didn't say anything I love doing that I
wasn't sure what point he was making I I
did see this part he goes I would never
be like
[Music]
to do this right because in order
I shouldn't be admitting this but
saving children right not as dubbed that
was great with you guys better not as
good you shouldn't have said that that's
weird probably makes your fans feel
uncomfortable as well
no dude you should save kids
all right so here we go here's coconuts
he's sweating
he's panicking for sure
um uh
yeah man this is tough bro because there
is brother
paralyzing to this you know yeah we are
what we didn't miss a day honestly
um
stuff
so much to uh
yep
that girl's like yep
by the way you want to know what Free
Speech means to these two Geniuses I'll
show you
Ellis Island free speech it's kind of
like is it even a thing not really yeah
I believe he's groping oh no the uh
Statue of Liberty shame on you guys
love ya
also furthermore
here is a artist interpretation of this
episode
oh
sad whatever that means I think she
means they're hurting
um current status
yeah uh Chris how you feeling bro
oh thank God thank God he had to cut
away the man he's a co-host of the show
he couldn't hold it for like 30 seconds
why is Coconuts there meanwhile Myron is
just sobbing in the bathroom like this
is quite a scene that's unfolding he's
sobbing because he likes saving men more
than kids no he's sobbing because he
dumped all of his money into a
condominium podcast Studio
that's being shut down and also doesn't
he have a bunch of Plan B in the
bathroom too
maybe he's taking it allegedly the whole
thing allegedly that's also what he's
allegedly yes he allegedly had a whole
bunch of Plan B
we're not 100 sure if his apartment is
the office I think I think it is
possible it I mean it's yeah maybe he
has a separate uh place where he
actually lives yeah I think he might
well that'd almost make it stupider
according to the caller we had he took
her there to the office yeah yeah it was
at the I think that's where he lives he
lives there I think he lives in his
podcast Studio yeah anyway let's see
what homie has to say here
I mean it's it's tough guys
because at the end of the day you guys
been with us from the beginning and
start uh the chat necessarily you guys
know the work we put in the the effort
the hours uh you guys send me you know
me Myron fresh Mo uh putting the work uh
shout out to the mods shout out to the
chat you know shout out to people that
actually tune in every day I see you
guys and this is one of those things man
we we put in you know the
the the energy wow they're really just
trying so much more to say than fresh
it's crazy but he even he is just like I
think just trying to buy time
yeah but I mean at least like he's not a
host he's not a host coconuts you're the
co-host man your name is first
fresh it's fresh and fit right
plus wood in tears
well you guys you guys saw our journey
from the start to finish when you first
broke 100 live viewers on stream
um
your entire
life to support people that you care
about
even that you're losing your job
you have hold on what right you're
talking about yeah I mean not only that
but like imagine giving up your entire
life who did that to well my record is
what do you care about my roommate a lot
of money
a lot more than a Fed makes yeah if
you're losing your job
you having social life you actually
being present at Vacations or oh he's
back also an environments and you say
you know what nah screw all that
we care about you guys over our feelings
how we feel at the moment and we won't
miss a show for you guys so come on bro
like Myron I mean I couldn't work
but mine goes extra mile just to give
you guys like obviously the soul bro
like like this guy like legit
ticket is life whatever you can keep it
yeah keep your soul
I wonder how the rumble uh migration is
going though so did we miss anything or
is that about it I mean there's stuff
throughout the whole thing but yeah that
uh that kind redditer uh let me open
this shout out their name because uh
they basically edited that Superman
and Hoops shout out
saving children right
that was great that was great okay he's
going to cry
cut the fresh panicking
um um
yeah man this is tough bro yeah sure and
here's the thing it's it's not about the
money man yeah it really isn't about the
money man I could walk away from all
this and be okay today you just said
you're all in you liar yeah and also if
it's not about the money then why is
this a big deal yeah just keep doing it
they're not getting kicked off YouTube
yeah keep it up brother just open a
patreon yeah
you know
that's it and you're good to go
if if we're not able
to be on YouTube we might not be able to
reach someone who really needs us yeah
that's why you're on YouTube if you guys
saw the amount of investors I get what
they say I was gonna end it tomorrow
yeah and I saw dude I was going to end
it tomorrow until I heard you berate a
19 year old drunk girl
about about
body counts
I saw you hop on that stream and put a
white hood on and throw up the sieg heil
and man right I was just like you know
what inspired life's worth living life's
worth living it's fine can we show that
or is that like way too crazy wait he
did that yeah yeah uh-huh oh was he was
that in response to a coconut stain or a
uh he's sitting he's sitting no he's
sitting next to snico
here I'll put on screen right now I
won't I won't show it to the audience
because it's probably
that's that's him right there
hey
dude he did some crazy on that
stream said a bunch of slurs
right oh right he was dropping yeah what
we know he did I mean he just like
openly because uh it's just so blatant
uh Hassan's uh nickname that he has is
just oh yeah
got him
video
the question is who else is going to do
it nobody's gonna do it man it's only
you guys yeah there's no other red
colors out there
I'll do it
I'll take care of the Restless men of
the world wait they're kind of doing
their boy reload Tony Brown town right
yeah so this is where it gets
interesting for me
they won't say why now I've been on
YouTube for a long time I've been
suspended I've been I've got two strikes
I've been through all this when you
get punished
when you get specifically removed for
the partner program you know what
happened it is communicated to you
guarantee
so they're basically trying to say did
they say why they think it happened or
they're saying we have no idea
uh I didn't see any any specifics
I think it's because uh they said
anything they say things that are not uh
that are not a PC
well that's a mildly to put it but the
reason that I'm almost sure of
is um
that they just had two strikes and they
keep saying slurs
and keep doing terrible things that they
know is putting them at risk which they
said at the beginning they said listen
we have up edgy people on
goes with the territory
but there's a conspiracy theory going
around which I personally don't believe
but it is interesting that they got
kicked out for filing a ton of false
copyright claims on competitors
and critics and critics so here so here
is how and why they got fired uh this
lady says they were reporting their
competitors for copyright infringement
in an attempt to get them de-platformed
while YouTube doesn't like when you do
that too many times without cause
so these got heated instead
I don't know how she knows that
well so it's not just her there's quite
a few people talking about it and it's
coming from the fact so they did do that
um about a year ago particular that they
do that they went all out and copyright
struck a bunch of channels including
this guy and including uh ab and preach
right
um which they made a video about it at
the time it was part of their life even
a thing full soccer yeah of course right
we love Free Speech but we uh go out of
our way to try and uh
squash all of our critics that even a
thing
um so that is interesting although in my
experience I find it very unlikely that
it was because of that and not just
because of community guidelines
violation repeated Community guidelines
and it was also about a year ago that
that happened
and uh you'd think that they would have
gone YouTube comes out a year later
listen don't they don't give a
about the copyrights up the only way
they would intervene is if they were
putting in false information saying they
own a video that they don't
to take something down that YouTube
doesn't like but if they're like it's
been accused of that
actually
uh have they is that what they were
doing I think that this I watched this
guy's video last night and I I don't
remember I guess we could just let me
watch maybe he talks about it but um
that you ask well fresh and fit hired a
two dollar attorney and a seven Cent
paralegal to spam out copyright strikes
across all of the platform targeting
certain content creators fresh and fit
one of these content creators to lose
their monetization they wanted these
content creators to lose their entire
Channel they wanted me the lead to lose
my channel they wanted me
about a big mistake brother yeah real
big mistake they hired that two dollar
attorney and that two dollar attorney
put ten yeah where can I get me a two
dollar attorney
sounds good sounds like a good ass deal
I don't care how bad they are the
copyright strikes against me let's take
a look this is their what their attorney
filed again over a year ago says thank
you for your submission it is okay this
is actually interesting so it says
copyright owner fresh and fit
I'm just gonna play it sorry guys I just
got to do that under review to ensure
it's valid here is the information you
filled out here we go here we go
copyright owner name fresh and fit now
you only need three to lose your channel
and this guy hit me again I don't
because there it's their name and their
content YouTube will not punish them
because they they just assume because of
the neutral uh
necessity that they have as a platform
that everything is in good faith and any
legal issue needs to be resolved between
the parties separately
so I'm not thinking that in my opinion
being with 10. each one of those 10 was
fraudulent and it was against YouTube's
terms of service now I rarely use fresh
and fits content when I did it was
always under fair use so imagine this
okay that's why I was
that was the part I was trying to
remember so he's saying
he's saying it was fair use he was using
content but he was saying I rarely use
their content when I did it was fair use
I think he's implying that he was issued
copyright strikes for where it
wasn't even against me using there thank
you here is the infant fit now you only
need three if that's true he would have
shown an affiliate free to lose your
channel and this guy hit me with 10.
each one of those 10 was fraudulent and
it was against YouTube's terms of
service now I rarely use fresh and fixed
content when I did it was always under
fair use so imagine this two dollar
attorney tries to attack me it could be
true that I use their content but I use
their content 8 18 for 20 seconds but
listen if I use your content for 20
seconds you better believe I'm using it
under fair use I'm a goddamn attorney
let's go are you kidding me oh but
YouTube's not already knew that that
attorney was on some BS we are concerned
that some of the information in your
takedown request may be fraudulent oh yo
there you go so they were getting
reprehended or reprimanded by YouTube
please understand that YouTuber sees a
large amount of fraudulent con uh
copyright take down results and we take
this abuse of that process very
seriously YouTube okay wait let me read
that whole because I've never seen that
before mm-hmm
we remind you that in your allegation of
copyright infringement you stated that
you are authorized to act on behalf of
the owner of an exclusive right that is
allegedly infringed and acknowledge that
any person who knowingly material
misrepresents that material activity is
infringing yada yada you also said you
understand that abuse of this form will
result in termination of your YouTube
account
for each video in question please
explain how you're authorized to make
this claim
if we don't receive a detailed
explanation within seven days your
YouTube account may be terminated oh
damn whoa Sam I'm trying to say so this
implies here
that yeah they were trying to claim
video that they weren't in right now
this was over a year ago but maybe they
started doing it again and they were
already on thin ice and that's why they
got bopped it says you may be able to
avoid termination if you retract your
takedown request
[Music]
so maybe you should do so please reply
to this email I hereby retract my claim
of corporate infringement
wow
so these morons could I mean they could
have been terminated for any number of
valid reasons it really seems like
there's a lot of angles that could have
which is just makes it all the better I
mean what morons
YouTube sent me the entire email chain
of the correspondence that the YouTube
team had with fresh and fits attorney in
that seven Cent paralegal guys when I
woke up to this here boy
I
think it was scrolling I was like oh my
God
the email chain shows this is the lead
attorney yeah I wasn't familiar with him
but I watched a bunch of this video last
night and I was really enjoying them
holy smokes this is really good stuff I
had no idea YouTube Team knew that those
10 copyright strikes against me were
fraudulent YouTube gave fresh and fit
seven days to apologize and retract each
one of those 10 fraudulent copyright
strikes against me you may be a able to
avoid termination if you retract your
takedown this is nuts they said take it
back if you want to avoid determination
of your channel take this back
did they I've dying to know
back where it came from please
that if they did not retract those
fraudulent claims against me their
entire account would be terminated they
even explain how to do it they're like
listen paralegal if you don't know how
to do it please reply to this email with
quote I hereby retract my claim
of copyright infringement period
the YouTube team so what happened well
the attorney apologized retracted each
one of them what a scum telling you
holy there might be something to
this I I totally I yeah it looks like
there is it's claims and YouTube allowed
their channel to stay up think about it
fresh and fit higher that two dollar so
they were on thin ice that's what I'm
talking right stuff yeah and then I also
know that they were harassing Abba and
preach with copyright surprised
they never did that to us
uh I maybe they have more sense than to
with yeah because you're the worst
person on YouTube that you could do that
too except with the possible exception
of this guy right the lead attorney yeah
he takes no prisoners yeah wow so these
guys are even dumber than I thought um
wow and that's what's crazy is like this
is pretty crazy and it still could be
another reason that they got banned
because they're they're so stupid in so
many ways fantastic that it's still
unclear
but yeah I mean I think that there's
there's a decent argument that this
might have had at least something to do
with it a contributing fact it could
have been a whole picture where they're
like yeah guys yeah exactly they need to
go
um Abba and preach are using the coconut
and Barbados meme uh what happened
should it happen uh hopefully you guys
are also using the omelet of knowledge
ma'am
what should have happened happened and
it is what it is there he is with those
awesome tags I actually followed that
one come on what should have happened
happened yeah you said omelet and
knowledge
what happened should have happened what
should have happened happened and yeah
you grab that sack already that's a good
one
coconuts and Barbados
you like that right coconuts and
Barbados yes you foul I'm about to hit
up h3h3 I'm like yo listen my enemy of
my enemies my friend
but still thanks for the rip
it is good I agree
coconuts in your divorce
love it
let's see here
yeah they
this is really stunning The Venue where
they filmed the show also yeah they're
being kicked out we talked about that
the misogynistic fresh and fit bug has
been canceled by YouTube The Venue where
they filmed the shows also asking them
to vacate it's so good partner program
just keep it straight we saw this
already
forty thousand likes in in this clip
they uh I believe talk specifically
about the getting kicked out aspect of
it but uh okay now we got a very
important announcement for you guys did
we see that part earlier now I'm getting
good stories gonna be the same bro
has been kicked off the YouTube Partner
program just keep it straight if you
look right now you can't even super chat
or you can't even super chat right now
yep uh so this is the beginning of the
end of this era
um we're working no this is just to try
to this is just the end of the end
there's no you know I mean you're done
come to a middle ground and you know
work together and figure this out but
for now we don't even know why we yeah
we don't know the specific okay so
they're saying they don't know why but
that's a total lie a thousand percent
they know they know which
yeah if if that is true that they one
thousand percent know why what is more
likely for them to be vague about the
reason that they got banned the
copyright because it makes them looks
there's no way because if it's if they
got banned for just popping off with
some like crazy ass opinion you know
they love that they love that but no
we're like we don't know why you're
right
because there's no way to spin that
where they don't look like total
idiots and losers and babe they were
called out about it a year ago holy
man I think that might have been what
happened
when you guys send me your DMs and say
yo you saved my life yo you sent me a
picture of your credit score yo my girl
is making sandwiches now or whatever it
is right okay we saw this yeah yeah
I didn't want to have to say
that all right whatever we got it
we got it so um rest in peace boy my
heart goes out to these two great guys
yeah couldn't have happened to worse
people I mean better people I don't know
Karma okay
let me go to the rumble page you do that
first when we're done talking about
fresh and Fit I have
something massive to show you can we see
how many supporters they have
like members or like subs or whatever
yeah probably doesn't say that publicly
so I mean 400 000 views on Rumble
there's no way nah dude come on Rumble
stop fronting
no shot
and by the way this video on YouTube
they posted the same video to YouTube I
noticed this was one of the ones that
had like 40 000 views well they did tell
Their audience to go to rumble I think
this was maybe before
uh or maybe I don't think so yeah maybe
not if you scroll down you'll see the uh
the emergency meeting episode here dude
they all have a ton of views four
hundred thousand six hundred thousand
their emergency meeting has 500 there's
no way
possible
you see what they're doing but friends
they're not live right they're they're
playing a pre-record
you know we were with that I don't know
on some level this is live let me show
you guys are a priority and at the same
time you come first so I mean yeah we
handled the description of course but
you know
um everyone being secure in their job
but at the same time it's like obviously
we want more reach because we're more
reach all right thank you coconut
right uh what did you have for us Dan
Zach you there
the whole time
everybody
I'm here sorry I didn't get to the
button quick enough okay it's fine Zach
can you hit me with a drum roll please
this is very drum roll worthy what I'm
about to show y'all
okay
here it comes
no the penguin got arrested
Rudy giuliani's mug shot has dropped
gorgeous wow that's my new profile pic
so the Trump one should be soon to
follow right tomorrow
it's all going down so
uh
the Republican uh debate is tonight that
Trump is not participating in org which
is horrible but he uh
you know has to turn himself in
uh to get mugshotted for this case in
Georgia and he's doing it tomorrow
morning the morning after the Republican
debate
he didn't have like the deadline is not
up
I think that he is intentionally doing
it the morning after the Republican
debate because it's going to completely
kill the news cycle of anybody talking
about it's pretty slick he would do that
he would although if it's like a total
disaster how could it be a disaster a
bunch of bozos just talking about
nonsense yeah and it's just like
because that's happening late at night
tonight
and then first thing tomorrow all
anybody is going to be talking about is
the Trump arrest thing shut up I think
he uh I think he planned that out put
that Rudy shot up again
okay second I cannot get over how
penguin SQ is that is straight up
disgusting that man was dragged out of a
sewer
and forced into a cage you guys are not
Tough Enough
it's awesome very good Rudy
bring those tits over here the cops will
like bring those tits away
bring that nice over here give me
those tits excuse the expression all
right so we're actually running low on
time so I'll just cut I'll talk about
fousey because I wanted to say something
about that okay so
fousey is not doing well
clearly he was arrested yesterday
and like a really
he was having like a well hold on I
think he had was he 51.50
that's what I think happened which is
the best outcome I think I believe
somebody mentioned this morning that TMZ
reported that
which is kind of crazy that was in TMZ
uh yeah here it is Cam just sent the
link
and a b uh the clip was absolutely wild
man it was just wild wild
foreign
fousey brought to hospital by cops
mental health check after live stream
rant so there you go the cops were
pretty good I gotta say I don't know if
it's they thought that they knew he was
live because he told them
or
they're just patient cops but I was
afraid he was going to resist or
something yeah yeah I was like please
don't resist bro please
and he didn't he didn't at all actually
it was very compliant with them
but well he did scream on the top of his
lungs and their faces but he didn't like
do anything like aggressive other than
yell
when they said you're under arrest he
complied right true
um or not under arrest but I guess they
just started handcuffing him so this was
all brought on there was some troll who
kept calling him and being like I know
where you live I'm gonna hurt your
family and he kept answering the call on
stream
and then I guess he just got super
scared called the police
and was like this guy's threatening me
and then the cops the the
answer dispatch rightfully was confused
she's like okay well who is he what does
he look like
and then he was like okay if you're not
coming then
he's here he has a gun to my head help
me help me please
and so then I got swarmed by police
and he got arrested
and you know though I I've been kind of
trying to
he's fallen in
after the big controversy happened with
the girl at the airport
I disengaged a little bit
I disengaged a lot of it and
it's interestingly that at that same
moment
it's almost like it was a positive for
for him because like all of a sudden he
started befriending fresh and fit
sneako saying that was snico Aiden Ross
it's like oh it's like oh you may have R
worded this girl let's hang dog
and then from that it's crazy it really
did happen from that event I feel like
yeah 100 because after that event I was
like oh this is this is gonna fizzle out
now
because a lot of his audience were were
our people
but after that
he started blowing up his views were
like 50 000 because he was hanging out
with Aiden Ross yeah and snico and all
these little uh you know all these kids
from these communities started following
him
and they're little pieces of too I
was in the chat saw what they're saying
they're all like we're just here for
Aiden to watch you have a meltdown
like like real nasty
basically
and um
apparently he hadn't slept in two days
he also said I haven't taken my meds in
two days at one point
during this this final stream
and I I mean listen my final advice to
him which I think is proven to be
good advice I think is that I just don't
think
that this type of lifestyle is
compatible
with uh who he is yeah
I mean it's really
um
you know
has proven himself uh Unworthy of having
a platform frankly
I I personally have been avoiding the
topic because I just I don't want to
feed into whatever is going on with him
you know what I mean yeah
that's why I don't put it in the title
that's why I don't you know click bait
it
and I put it at the end of the episode
but I just wanted to say that honestly
there are people really did kind of drop
the ball on this like kick his stream
was on Kick there was like 80 000 people
watching a very dangerous situation I
was watching the live stream it was
scary
he was interacting with chat he was
doxing himself he was on the phone
saying his exact hotel and room number
he was giving the address of some of
this guy he thought it was this guy's
address he was calling the police like
this was a very dangerous situation
and it's very fortunate that you know he
wasn't killed by the police
I feel like
that was one of the outcome that was one
of the outcomes that was on the table
and so
it's actually insane that they really
don't care
I feel like if that was on Twitch it
would have ended way earlier and
potentially could have brought him down
a little bit
because he was getting all charged up
from the stream the stream numbers he
kept talking about how he's the biggest
viral sensation
and then of course
the I know these guys don't give a
but Aiden Ross stiko fresh and fit
they don't care
uh about they don't I don't even think
they believe mental health is a real
thing so
can't expect us to say anything to them
but this was a guy who wasn't doing well
that they just gave they just poured
attention onto
um
there's a clip of him with snico
and he keeps getting text messages
and um
I don't know why but he started to panic
and he was hitting himself in the head
he's like I can't stop getting text
messages people need to stop texting me
and snika was like
rattled by it
but you know they don't want to help him
they just want to keep farming the views
that didn't slow him down and
I'm not quite sure what else to say
about it
I mean I'm glad he wasn't hurt well I
wasn't uh watching the whole thing until
you know Arch chat was blowing up about
what was going on and uh
and then I just started seeing our chat
just became like oh my god what the
a bunch and I was like what's happening
our chat like are are the H3 Crews Oh
you mean us watching it yeah right yeah
yeah yeah uh like last night I was
seeing like every people be like holy
I couldn't believe what I've seen
yeah no surreal yeah so I tuned in like
right as the cops were about to show up
and you know I don't spend a lot of time
on Kik surprise surprise but I saw on
the sidebar that fousey was by far the
biggest stream on the platform at that
moment because of what was going on by
far and the second highest it was
suggesting to me on the sidebar was
train wreck just and I took this
screenshot this is what train wreck
who's like the face of this platform
owner well right yeah he's
just doing the slots
doing the slots
as this guy is about to get
oh sorry I didn't switch potentially
Murder My Boss by the police
there he is that's a good plan I mean
it's a good owner right there
or whatever the he is oh Ambassador
yeah
did kick really tweet this what you got
kick tweeted out hashtag freefousi
because he would when he was being taken
out by the police oh this isn't doctor
this is 100 real
that's such a crazy thing we
don't know for sure but I I don't when
he was being taken out of the hotel room
by the police he was saying free fousey
hashtag free fousey
is this how can we how do we know if
this is really where did it come from
personally I wouldn't be surprised if
it's uh real because they post the crazy
on Tech talk on the official one of
like adding Ross like fat shaving some
girl okay screaming like crazy so
I could believe it's real but I would
like to know for sure yeah I I 100 I
believe it could be it's psychotic man
oh wait here's here's potential proof
the shady as from Kik you posted
free fousey in support of your
influencer fousey then deleted the Tweet
when the pressure got high so they're
coming from a different angle like oh
you're a fake fan
delete
it looks like they did do it here it is
yeah I'm seeing the chat now confirm
that uh people saw us that's
crazy
bruh that's what happens when you have a
streaming platform with unlimited uh
budget and no oversight no moral I mean
the whole thing is built on gambling
they they literally
crypto gambling like right right
regulate a crypto gamma yeah like
there's no ethical guidelines there's no
Northern Light in terms of like uh
you know company welfare uh streamer
welfare here is a clip apparently this
was the doxer who was calling him and
with them and apparently he's
calling the cops on fousey on Kick
streaming on Kick did I even show this
guy I'm not gonna show it I'm not gonna
play it I was just showing I haven't
even like pulled it up on screen I just
feel like so he's on calling the police
on fousey
nice enjoy and then you know they're
again train wreck just sitting
there happily gambling owner of the
platform Who's online during this whole
thing and definitely knows about it
it his his actual role at kick has
always been kind of ambiguous so like I
don't know he's an advisor it seems like
people or whatever yeah I think it's
fair to say he's the face of kick yeah
he has he was like launched it and like
you know is was the biggest advocate for
it so I think that's fair to say he he
has pull yeah exactly and he definitely
saw it because everyone was talking
about it I mean the views were going up
like crazy and it was all happening
so
that was really sad that kind of I mean
there was no when he got in that state
of mind there was really nothing anyone
could do there was people that were
trying to call him and calm him down and
it was just making him more excited yeah
so
there wasn't really anything at that
point you could do but I do think if the
stream was removed it would have helped
uh train wreck is co-founder of kick in
his own bio co-founder and advisor so
yeah he could have definitely done
something what a loser piece of
they genuinely for all I know it
was train wreck that tweeted that from
their social account it was like late at
night I mean who you know what I mean I
can't imagine many people worked there
yeah
but what a dude ah God I don't know how
this guy has fans he is such a scumbag
just such an unmitigated worthless
unethical piece of
God he sucks man
anyway listen I I
it's hard to point fingers and past
blame and stuff uh it's uh
you can say it what the one thing I
think for sure would have been good is
if Kip ended that stream yeah that's the
one thing I can say that should have
happened that would have helped yep
and it went all the way
like it was dragged on they never shut
it off
no they never did like he he got taken
away by the police
and then it was just like and his camera
empty hotel room his feed and then
eventually the security guard that
fousey had came back and turned off the
pack and it you know defaulted to his uh
be right back be right back screen or
whatever and uh
I don't know did it ever turn off
yeah somebody shut it off at some point
but but um
yes yes I genuinely think in my opinion
that people from kick potentially even
train wreck
we're watching the numbers and thought
it was good for the platform yeah and
made the conscious decision to let it
ride baby
good stuff
and then there yeah I don't know what
else to say but other than that yeah
but uh guys uh Hey listen it's not all
about it's not all uh bad news over a
kick if you use code H3 you can get a
150 percent bonus on your first deposit
that's right
that's right we don't need your IDs all
we need is your crypto account guys we
accept eth we accept Bitcoin 150 bonus
that's right come on down baby
oh
let's yeah Foose someone said kid fousey
was different than twitch fousey which
yeah
that's that that's true because kick
fousey was like your brain on when
you're under the influence of
these types of people
and then his negative kind of behavior
as that we perceived as negative
behavior was being reinforced as good
behavior
at some point somebody called him when I
was watching the some of the clips of
what happened I think it was Aiden Aiden
did call him yeah Aiden at some point
called him and was like
admittedly was trying to like talk him
down a little bit but his way of talking
him down which I guess I don't know when
somebody's in that state maybe this is
the right approach but he was telling
him this is the best thing you've ever
done like you're you're winning at life
right now so don't screw it up
so
by one token you know further
encouraging it like telling them yeah
yeah no this is actually all great but
just you got to be a little more careful
with sort of the uh he's a the
message he tried at least yeah yeah I
mean good that he tried more than anyone
at kicked did yeah when I saw yeah Aiden
was telling to to go to sleep like
rest
when that guy ticked him off more even
though I think Aiden's a and
I'm not even gonna say anything nice
about him it it yeah I thought
it was good that he called though I
thought it was good he called yeah and
you know
at a certain point though he stopped
answering his phone and he was just like
I'm not answering any more calls
all these people telling me to turn
off the Stream
uh
that's it that's that's what happened
but you know I was hoping that they
would take him
to uh a facility for uh
taking care of his monitoring evaluation
yeah and and that seems to be what they
did so that was the best outcome in
terms of what happened uh-huh
yeah early in the night it was a whole
thing fousey was getting at fights and
smacking people he was obviously his
behavior was getting really wild but
I don't know these these buffoons they
don't they don't understand mental
illness or they don't
I see I'm going to call it illness it's
like uh
you know different conditions that
people have
or maybe that's giving them too much
benefit a doubt maybe they just don't
give a I don't know
that's what that is eh
anyway I wish him uh you know
I wish she gets better and kind of I
hope he takes my advice to Heart
I think he would be happier
long term and more peaceful
if he you know
just moved on to having a normal type of
Life got out of being an influencer it's
just when you get all that attention
just unfortunately you know it sucks
because it's a it's the thing that a lot
of people want to do and a lot of people
stuff that people like doing you get a
ton of attention you make a lot of money
so it's hard to come to this realization
that
it's not it's only hurting you
and it may not be the best path for you
I don't know
unfortunately
there it is
I don't want to say illness because it
feels derogatory like it's it's a it's a
you know what I mean we all have our
to to deal with it's not it's not
like he's sick that he can be cured of
his sickness or something
you know we all got to deal with
and
it's like it's a condition right that he
has it's different than some people have
and I have a con I have conditions that
are different I don't consider it an
illness you know what I mean
just something you deal with
uh dude it was so wild he had a
bodyguard there
the whole time it was it was just such a
wild scene I I was surreal I didn't know
how to describe it watching that was
just surreal
I thought I was watching like a movie or
something or it did just didn't feel
real I don't know
well unfortunately it was very real
too real
alrighty guys
well I guess I gotta connect with his I
don't think Hassan cares but we'll
probably be here tomorrow
with the kovitz stuff yeah I guess we'll
find out I mean uh but if it's just like
the three of us
again
I'll tell I'll see if Hassan cares if he
if he doesn't then
we'll go from there
so Maples I think we'll probably see you
guys tomorrow morning okay
um so thank you guys everyone for
watching
thank you to Donna Klein
the milkweed mama
[Music]
um
thank you to all you guys watching uh
appreciate y'all so much thank you
so we'll see you tomorrow morning
probably
see you Friday probably as well
have a great evening everyone I don't
know where the thanks for watching card
is
thanks for watching card so
um
[Music]
free free